Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim. Weltall. Ich kann dir eins sagen, Tim, woanders ist auch Scheiße.
Logbuch:Netzpolitik, die Ausgabe Nummer zweihundertfünfunddreißig. Haben wir und wir haben den, na? Siebzehnten November zweitausendsiebzehn.
Und ich hatte hier die Trump-Tweets offen und habe gedacht, mal gucken, welchen davon ich jetzt bringen kann. Sowas. Ja.
Tja und dann komme ich mit sowas. Ja. Tja. Was das mit der Spontanität? Ja. Alles nicht so einfach.
Ja, erstmal. Ja, warum du mir mit Weltraum kommst. Dabei habe ich dich nie groß und dick genannt.
Oh man, äh, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Trump Tweets… irgendwie stehe ich da schon drüber.
Ja, das ist, das kommt halt.
Dummheit ist halt auch so, ich meine so äh dumme Äußere, also also sowohl Äußerungen von dumm als auch generell dumme Äußerungen oder halt im schlimmsten Fall beides,
Das bekämpft man eigentlich durch ignorieren am besten, ne? Das ist halt einfach der alte Treufaktor, einfach ins leere laufen lassen, das äh hilft.
Ja da das mag sein, aber wenn das halt der Präsident ist, dann kannst du kannst nicht immer sagen,
Nordlissing, I'm not your Follower und Twitter, dann drückt er irgendwann den Bombenknopf,
Ich habe heute Morgen noch äh hier äh äh also heute ganz früh am Morgen vor unserer Sendung Anfang. Habe ich mir das angeschaut, dass hier gerade in den USA gucken, dass sie ihn, dass sie irgendwie klar geworden ist, dass sie irgendwie noch ein paar Safe-Cards an diesen Bombenknopf machen müssen.
Ja, so.
Ja okay.
Dieser dieser.
Das hätten sie schon gemacht. Jetzt kommt einfach mal Daid Cook.
Wir haben hier noch jemanden sitzen, der schon die, die schon die ganze Zeit mitsagen möchte, aber so höflich ist wie ein japanischer Gastgeber,
und wartet, dass sie vorgestellt wird. Die zweitbeste Ökonomie der Podcastszene, die zweitbeste. Nicht ökonomial.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wer das.
Secondback Best Economy. We have the best, but you you can bese.
A und Trump Witz. Oh.
Oh Gott, live.
Okay, der war schon.
Ich war wirklich auf.
Ich mache jetzt dein Twitter aus.
Der war wirklich ein bisschen ein Meter.
Constanze ist da, hallo Konstanz. Machen wir es mal.
Constanze ist da, to make, Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Even Greater Gan.
Ja und ich möchte anfügen, dass ich nur hier bin, weil sie sich eure Kommentatoren beschwert haben, als ich so selten komme. Mhm.
Na ja, sie haben sich beschwert, dass zu wenig Damen hier sind. Das ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, sie haben sich ganz konkret beschwert.
Konkret sogar Constanze sogar konkret.
Natürlich könnte doch, also könnt ihr doch selber als Sockenpuppe gewesen sein.
Das ist möglich. Das diskutieren wir jetzt nicht.
Na, ich habe schon geguckt, ich kenne ja den IP Advis Range aus dem du normalerweise kommst und,
Das ist entweder Deutsche Bahn oder das Netzpolitikbüro. Die habe ich ja äh nein nein, also das äh das war ein legitimer, ein echter Kommentar.
Von jemand, den wir auch kennen. Der war stimmt. Henning, genau.
Ja, gestern noch gesehen.
Kannst du mal sehen.
Bei Raumzeit live.
Im Planetarium.
Im Planetarium zu Berlin.
Ich war beschäftigt, du musst sagen wie's war.
Ja, also ähm ich hatte ja die Raumzeitfolge schon gehört über das Planetarium. Die war ja schon das Play-Tage äh ist ja auch seit einiger Zeit
hier die Schirmherrschaft oder wie auch immer vor die präsentierender Sponsor von Raumzeit und war sehr froh jetzt endlich mal einen äh Anlass zu finden, da auch tatsächlich hinzugehen.
Ach, du warst noch nie da. Ah.
Ich war noch nie da, war das erste Mal und ähm war begeistert von dieser Anlage,
Hat großartig funktioniert für einen Podcast. Ich fand das also ist auf ist sehr, sehr beeindruckend, was da an an Bildern gespielt werden kann, was man da so sieht, die Technik ist natürlich auch beeindruckend. Die Leut.
Vielleicht erstmal kurz erklären, was eigentlich passiert ist, also ähm haben wir?
Ja, wir haben sogar hier in der Sendung.
Ach so, ja okay, aber vielleicht hat ja jetzt das.
Ich habe hier in der Sendung Tickets gekauft,
Ey, zeig Großplanetarium zu Berlin, ein Planetarium, also eine ein äh Kino mit Bildschirm an der Decke,
in der Kuppel,
äh wird hauptsächlich gerne äh da wird natürlich entsprechend mit mit einer hundertachtzig Grad Späre entweder halt hundertachtzig Grad Bilder dargestellt oder viel Weltraum. Man kann da schön durch den Weltr.
Genau genommen sind's sogar dreihundertsechzig Grad, aber halt nur halbe Kuppel. Man sagt Haftdome. Haftung.
Harf Dome und da fand ein Podcast statt.
Man Fulldom, ne, der Dom, ein Dom ist ja eine halbe Kugel, also von daher ist es voll doof.
Na wollt ihr vielleicht den Nichtberliner mal sagen, wo das ist in Berlin? Da wird vielleicht nicht jeder wissen. Ja, aber wir haben zwei in Berlin.
Äh Prenzlauer Berg.
Genau, direkt sozusagen hier, nein, es gibt ja noch einen.
Nee, welche? Wie heißt die.
Es gibt noch, es gibt noch ein zweites, ja.
Reden wir aber nicht. Wir reden von.
Gehört aber zur selben Stiftung.
Nur in die nicht Berliner werden vielleicht nicht wissen.
Die Nicht-Berliner wissen, also dass es zwei.
Verzeihung, ja, das äh.
Also es ist, es ist halt das äh Zeisc
Planetarium, was halt jüngst äh komplett umgerüstet wurde und die Technik ähm ja wurde dann auch im Rahmen der Veranstaltung ordentlich genutzt, zumindest die äh Projektion, also alles, was dabei so mit Laserbeamern gemacht wird
und ganz zum Schluss kam dann auch nochmal der Sternprojektor zum Einsatz.
Der Sternenprojekte ein ein lustiges,
lustig geformtes Gerät, Fährtanf aus dem Boden hoch, wie ich gehört habe, fährt das äh also wirklich aus dem Boden und zwar aus dem Erdreichboden, weil das Ding steht auf irgendwie einem Fahrstuhl, der bis in den Keller geht,
Ähm,
Und das, den braucht man unter anderem, weil das auch wirklich zu Wartungszwecken schwer zu bewegen wäre dieses Teil. Also man hätte jetzt gedacht, okay, komm, die Treppe ist noch groß genug, zwei Mann, pack an. Äh so einfach nicht,
fährt fährt also wirklich von unten aus dem Keller hoch.
Genau, also während einer Veranstaltung ist ja in so einer Parkposition direkt äh da drunter, aber man kann ihn auch bis nach ganz nach unten fahren, so läuft das.
Also ähm es gab so der Gast war Jochen.
Jochen Liske. Liske. Ähm Hamburger Stern warte.
Liske. Ähm Hamburger Sternwerter und ähm.
Der ist kein Sternwert, der ist äh also du meinst, ach er ist derjenige, der mir die Sterne.
Das das war also ich fand's ein bisschen eh so ist zwar ist doch die äh,
European Space Opservutori, bei dem er und das stand halt irgendwann an einer Stelle riesengroß in diesem Planetariumshimmel eh so und dieses Logo sieht jetzt auch echt so aus als kürz.
Doch ein bisschen aus wie eh so.
Im Reformhaus auf den Dinkel kleben, so, ne? Das war eigentlich so,
und ähm ja, aber das war Setting hat äh gestimmt. Wunderbare Atmosphäre kann man,
Äh kann man so wirklich empfehlen? Ähm.
Gibt's dann auch bald als Audioaufzeichnung.
Aber das ist, wird mit.
Selber näher.
Videoaufzeichnung, also wir haben's probiert, ein bisschen mit zu dokumentieren, aber das ist de facto kaum aufzeichnen, bar, also man müsste halt eine extrem lichtstarke dreihundertsechzig Grad Kamer.
In dieses diese Maschinerie, die äh hat das nicht rausrendern und dann kommt das auf YouTube und dann haut man sich hier seinen Cardboard unter äh iPhone oder Smartphone vor den Augen und.
Ist in der Tat etwas, worüber man mal nachdenken kann, was aber jetzt nicht so auf Knopfdruck passiert.
Nee, ich finde, dieses äh Planetarium, ich war da nach dem Umbau zwar noch nicht, aber davor weigt der Häufer, die machen ja da auch Hörspiele und so,
ist was vollkommen anderes äh sozusagen sich das später abzuspielen, weil zum einen das ist ja alles so, ist relativ schall gedämpft. Man hat da die Umgebung ist sehr fokussiert auf den Ton, den man da hört und die Bilder
man hat wenig Ablenkung und dann hat man diese sehr angenehme Sitzposition, die haben sie bestimmt beibehalten oder? Diese,
und man ist total fokussiert auf das, was man erlebt und das kann man, glaube ich, nicht so richtig replizieren. Und außerdem ist natürlich diese, der diese riesige Projektionsfläche auch erschlagend. Ich finde nicht, dass eine Aufzeichnung in gleicher Weise kann.
Nee, das ist ja auch das Soundsystem. Ich meine, die haben da halt so einen, so ein, so ein virtuelles dreihundertsechzig Grad Audiosystem, die können da irgendwie bis zu zweiunddreißig virtuelle Klangquellen.
Zweiunddreißig virtuelle Tipps raus.
Haben wir auch teilweise probiert das Intro, Autro, Raumzeit hat jetzt ein neues, das ist dann halt auch insound äh produziert worden quasi für den Abend,
kann man sogar noch aufwendiger machen indem du ja quasi du kannst ja quasi in so ein äh virtuellen Dom auch deine Klangquellen irgendwo hinsetzen und das dann dafür abmischen,
Ja, also du warst noch nicht mal feste Lautsprecherpositionen, weil das System halt in der Lage ist, beliebige Quellen zu erzeugen oder,
ne, also Orte quasi von wo der Sound scheinbar herzukommen scheint und ja, das ist jetzt so noch nicht äh vollständig genutzt, da müsste man ein bisschen mehr Zeit mit verbringen und die Vorbereitung war jetzt relativ,
Kurzfristig, wie das immer so ist, ne. Aber na ja, gibt's demnächst als Audioaufzeichnung funktioniert glaube ich auch ganz gut. Bin schon froh, dass die Aufnahmen geklappt hat.
Ja, ich vor allem die Erkenntnis, dass man tatsächlich wohl für dieses Live-Podcasting man braucht, irgendwie so ein icandy,
Also bei LMP zweihundert die Zeichnung von Roland haben da enorme, also die haben's einfach enorm rausgerissen,
einfach wirklich gute zwei Stunden nur in die Architektur geguckt, da sieht man sich ja auch irgendwann satt dran. Hier Raumzeit angereichert mit diesen ähm wenn dann eben die Rede war von Gravitationsfällen, dann hat man halt da oben irgendwie
die Gravitationsfällen rumwackeln sehen und es gibt auch eine Stelle im Podcast darf ich die schon spoilern?
Als der Gast mitten im Satz abbricht und sagt, boah warte mal, das ist aber jetzt eine geile Animation oder ganz kurz abbrechen und sie, boah krass,
Okay und dann versucht weiterzureden.
Eigentlich reden wir doch hier sozusagen über die Zukunft des Podcasts, denn wenn wir alle VR-Systeme, geiler haben, dann könnte man sich überlegen, wie man dann überträgt, weißt du, so. Man legt sich zu Hause auf die Couch, setzt sich sein VR-System auf und lässt sich mal so den Tim mit Kuppel.
Mein Reden seit Generatoren, ich meine seit seit ich seit ich Sendung mache.
Die haben sich auch viel zu lange Zeit gelassen, bis du dir endlich das Planetarium gebaut haben.
Ja, ich meine alle immer so, ja Tim, mach doch mal Video, mach doch mal YouTube und so weiter und das dieses ganze
fressen in die Kamera halten und dabei rumhüpfen. Ey, das ist so mehrwertfrei. Das äh bringt's einfach nicht. Aber wenn man halt wirklich
Gezielte visuelle Produktion macht so. Und das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Dom sein. Ich habe ja Raumzeit auch schon mal in Darmstadt äh live on Stage gehabt und da war's halt einfach eine in Anführungsstrichen normale Leinwand.
Ich habe einen Dom ist schon.
Dumm ist halt auch geil, aber wichtig ist halt, dass da eben sozusagen so äh visuelles Hirnfutter kommt, weil,
im Prinzip repliziert das ja auch das normale Hören eines Podcasts, wenn ihr jetzt Kopfhörer aufhast und du läufst durch die Gegend, dann ist es ja auch deshalb so geil, weil du immer so deine Wege und Erlebnisse, die Orte, wo du gerade bist, automatisch in deiner Erinnerung halt auch damit verknüpfst. Jeder kennt diesen Effekt so. Ich hab
X gehört und ich weiß heute noch, wie ich da im Urlaub irgendwo einen Berg hochgelatscht bin. Und das ne, die Erinnerung funktioniert einfach generell besser, wenn du eben Bilder dazu bekommst und genau das äh,
befördert dann eben auch so ein Setting wie in dem Planetarium.
Ja, großartig, ich freue mich, dass das jetzt regelmäßig äh kommt.
Ach, echt, wie, jetzt sag mal die Regelmäßigkeit.
Also das nächste Mal im halben Jahr erstmal, ob ich den Takt dann noch erhöhen kann, das wird man sehen, ja? Weil du brauchst halt das richtige Thema, dann brauchst du irgendwie einen Partner, du musst Termine machen und so weiter, es.
Dem niemand hat jemals gesagt, dass es leicht wird.
Ein halbes Jahr finde ich ja das doch ganz schön lang.
Ja, mal gucken, ne? War jetzt auch erste Mal und erstmal schauen wie's läuft und jetzt machen wir das im halben Jahr nochmal und vielleicht erhöhen wir auch den Takt, aber das heißt halt auch, was immer mit allem zu tun.
Vor allem, was da mal erhöht werden müsste, äh ist der Preis. Das war acht Euro. Äh sitzt zwei Stunden in diesem Ding.
Ich hätte sogar mal eine Karte, die haben ihre Hörspiele, weil sich unglaublich geil fand, äh auch mal so eine, die hat mal so eine Sommerkarte. Also das war toll. Das wäre überhaupt total.
Ich war nur einmal zum Hörspiel da, ich war total.
Es ist ein städtische Stiftung, also das ist sozusagen auch for the public, meines D.
Ja, stimmt, wir haben ja genug Geld. Berlin hat genug Geld. Dann müssen wir.
Ich finde das jetzt mal in Ordnung, weil.
Nein, ich will ja und es ich wollte die Kritik, das ist zu billig heißt natürlich einfach also für acht Euro war das wirklich ähm ne, was man da jetzt geboten bekommen hat, allein, dass diese Anlage angeht,
da war Personal ähm das Ding wurde bedient von einem Experten, wie es wenige gibt, wahrscheinlich, die das bedienen können und dürfen. Ähm und dass er jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass er keine Anlage, die irgendwie,
Bei Amazon bestellt werden kann. Das ist halt eine eine Spez.
Außer bei Amazon Prime natürlich.
Amazon Prime, vierundzwanzig Stunden Deliv,
kommt her, kommt der Fahrstuhl von unten aus deinem Boden. Nein, der ist da hätte war ich jetzt dann doch sehr überrascht, dass das ähm so günstig entweder möglich ist oder so stark subventioniert. Ich.
Einfach gesetzt, also die Veranstaltung kostet da mehr oder weniger immer das Gleiche und es sind halt irgendwie acht Euro normal, sechs Euro ermäßigt und so ist das halt einfach,
es ist halt ein Wissenschaftstheater, es geht da drum einfach die Öffentlichkeit möglichst günstig über alles Mögliche zu informieren.
Habt ihr ja auch gemacht, nicht wahr? A.
Ist ja ist toll, dann also ne, soll jetzt keine Kritik. Ich beschwere mich jetzt nicht und sage, nächstes Mal komme ich nicht, wenn das so billig bleibt
wirklich äh man hat da wirklich großartiges geboten bekommen. Wir haben da nur gestern halt auch nochmal im im Nachgang drüber gequatscht, weil,
Ich ja jetzt nur von der LMP zweihundert weiß, was mit so einer Veranstaltungsorganisation allein einhergeht,
Und ah gut, da war jetzt al.
Das war zu billig.
Ja, leider. Also großartig, großartige Sache kann ich nur empfehlen ähm wenn das äh dann demnächst regelmäßig im Planetarium stattfindet, freue ich mich da sehr dr,
So, jetzt kommen wir zum wahren Grund, warum du hier eingeladen bist, Konstanz. Wir laden dich ja nicht einfach nur ein, weil äh weil irgendjemand sich das wünscht, sei es auch Henning, ähm du hast äh einiges erlebt in,
In letzter Zeit und was natürlich auch in diesem Jahr schon wieder sehr, sehr umtriebig.
Umtriebig ist ja ein bisschen negativ konnotiert, oder? Ja, das klingt ja wie wie weiß auch eine Graube mein.
Warst gärig.
Aktiv ist das Wort, was du such.
Aktiv vier Jahre Snowden schreiben wir jetzt.
Naja, schon mehr, ne?
Schon mehr. Und ja, es stimmt, war ja immer, wann war das Sommer? War es seit Juni? Ja. Ähm das haben wir Frank und du zum Anlass genommen,
eure Texte,
zum zum Thema Snorden über die Jahre von äh vielen Freunden und Freiwilligen als Hörbuch einsprechen zu lassen und das jetzt ähm
Unter WWW Now you know Punkt I you Punkt EU ähm zu veröffentlichen,
Und das finde ich natürlich schon mal ein sehr schon mal an sich, ein sehr, sehr schönes Projekt. Wir haben da schon voll drüber gesprochen, du hast gesagt, man merkt da viel über die Zeit auch.
Ja, total,
mehr Sachen, also wir konnten natürlich nicht wissen, ob sich da jetzt viele melden. Das war so eine Idee, wir konnten ja nicht wissen, du willst ja viele Freiwillige auch wirklich
Zutrauen einzulesen und glaube, das ist auch nicht so einfach, weil man ja Texte für Print schreibt. Etwa so Zeitschriften und Zeitungen und Buchbeiträge,
und viele haben sich damit so ein bisschen schwer getan, weil ich neig.
Heißt Fatzkolumne.
Kolumnen, das war aber auch die FAS, also Frankfurter Allgemeinsonntagszeitung, da waren Spiegel bei ähm aber oft so Buchbeiträge, die haben wir teilweise gekürzt, weil die zu lang waren. Also so ein einfach, wir haben uns zu fünfzig hätten wir, glaube ich, rausgesucht,
weil wir ja nicht wussten wie viel melden sich. Wir haben aber deutlich mehr geschrieben. Vier Jahre ist nach langer Zeit. Ähm.
Bei dir wart ihr auch so klug, euch vorher die Rechte so äh auslegen zu lassen, dass ihr das durfte.
Haben wir,
Wir haben schon in der Mehl auch klar gemacht, wenn wir die Rechte nicht übertragen kriegen, die benutzen wir es einfach nicht. Wir wollten das frei und dann einer freien Lizenz raushauen und mit keimen und es sollte auch einfach von vornherein klar, dass wir zum Download machen. Aber ich habe natürlich dabei auch alles nochmal gelesen und dann beim Schneiden, ich habe das selber geschnitten,
bin ja noch nicht der Podcaster. Äh also ihr Watchme.
Holzhacker.
Nee, ich habe einfach eine Menge, das war interessant,
Also am lustigsten fand ich eigentlich den Chineseneffekt, weil er jetzt für zweitausenddreizehn, zweitausendvierzehn drüber schrieben, dann waren der immer die Chinesen, sondern durch die Russen und irgendwann merkst du, ja
zweitausendsechzehn geht es auf die Russen über und kriegst natürlich erst mit, wenn mal sowas über einen langen Zeitraum hörst.
Aber auch wie sich die politischen Kommentierungen geändert haben. Wir haben ja immer, wir haben ja meist so ein aktuelles Ding. Irgendwas, wo wir uns aufgehangen haben, also was gerade wieder rauskam. Und dann ist natürlich diese kommentierende Ebene der Politik drin und du merkst natürlich über die Zeit, wie sich das ändert.
Wie Facebook speichert unsere Daten zu.
Nee, das Jahr hat er meinen Snownbezug immer. Ja. Also wir haben.
Aber war denn nicht die erste des neuen Veröffentlichungen Prison und da dann halt der also.
Na fast. Also äh die, die wir hier wahrgenommen haben, ja, aber es gibt eigentlich noch eine davor, dass diese ähm was inneramerikanisch noch war. Aber hier für Europa ist das.
Ah die ähm Telefontelefon Vorratsseitenspeicherung. Ja.
Genau. Im Prinzip eingeschlagen, so richtig eingeschlagen, hat ja eigentlich erst auch,
ich habe auch viele, du vergisst total viel, irgendeine, ich rede darüber, ich mache auch Vorträge dazu, auch zu Einzelaspekten. Stellt euch nicht vor, wie viel man vergisst,
Also zu einfach tierisch viel.
Ich hab natürlich auch 'ne große Sammlung, äh weil ich ja auch öfter darüber schreibe, aber wann viele Details, die ich vergessen hab und die mich auch nochmal empört haben. Ich neige ja dazu, mich dann auch wieder zu ärgern über die Dreißigkeit und so. Ich war bin selber überrascht.
Wie viele Stunden sind das jetzt?
Mit so einem Trainer neununddreißig Minuten, dann fünfeinhalb Stunden. Aber wir haben das halt so ein bisschen. Wir wussten, niemand will fünf Stunden am Stück. Wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen aufbereitet. Man kann das in kleinen Schnipseln oder.
Kann das in Einzelstücken, in Ja.
Haben wir nicht gemacht, das zu kurz. Wir haben immer so zwei oder drei zusammengefüg.
Ach so, okay, ähm in Jahren und dann natürlich auch ganz einfach als Podcastfeed, was.
Nee, das hat uns jemand gebastelt, fand ich total nett. Also jemand hat sozusagen ja.
Drauf gekommen seid.
Ey, ich bin so unerfahren in sowas ich. Also ich kenne da ja nicht wahrscheinlich da mit diesem och boah, jetzt war schon ganz schön anstrengend, habe eine Menge gelernt, sagen wir mal so.
Hast du das am Ende nochmal von jemand anders durchhören lassen?
Äh nee, aber ich habe natürlich ein bisschen Erfahrung, weil ick ja beim Neusprechfunk auch, das Schneiden mache, so dass ich wusste, ich muss da noch aufronicken. Wie heißen die Aufhonig? Offhone. Ist das deutsch ausgesprochen.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht falsch.
Auf Honig, es musste noch auf Honig.
Habe mir jetzt auch das Programm zugelegt, war ganz interessant, weil ich auch nochmal gelernt, das zu bedienen. Ich benutze den nicht zum Schneiden, sondern Geburtstag für Hindenburg. Bei dem ich auch gut klarkomme. Aber es war einfach äh die Menge. Ihr könnt euch das vorstellen, ne? Du hast einfach einen Batzen, ganz viel Kommunikation,
Kommunikation. Ich habe halt einfach nicht gedacht, dass das so einen, dass sich so viele melden. Das ist einfach. Hat aber auch großen Spaß gemacht. Also war viel Arbeit,
Also äh Frank hat äh noch was interessantes Neues gelernt, nämlich äh Nikola, wir werden auch noch eingefangen wird mit der Webseitentechnik zu beschäftigen, wenn wir also es war ganz lustig, ja,
'ne Menge gelernt und total nette, sehr freundliches Feedback aus der verschiedenen Ecken.
Schön. Empfehlung, no you know Punkt EU,
dann warst du äh beim International Governance Forum und hattest da die die Freude, den Herrn Karl zu treffen.
Wilfried. Karl, der.
Auch vor ein paar Monaten mal kennengelernt.
Der Chef, der sieht es, genau, also der Reichste aus München an. Ähm,
Das war jetzt erst vor zwei Tagen. Ähm was ich mit dem mein Eindruck ist noch sehr frisch davon. Ich hätte den den Herrn natürlich noch nicht kennengelernt, aber ich habe natürlich ähm,
äh aufgrund der Tatsache, dass von seiner Biografie einige bekannt ist
hat er natürlich schon so ein bisschen so einen Eindruck, wie das wohl werden wird, aber die Diskussion war dann doch ein bisschen anders, als ich erwartet habe. Zieht es, ist ja so eine eine, ja, eine Behörde, die,
Gerade erst eigentlich ins Leben gerufen wird, die dem äh Bundesministeriums intersteht und die sich vor allen Dingen darum kümmern soll, irgendwie elektronische Geräte, die die Strafverfolger, Geheimdienste, ähm also,
vielleicht sogar Militär, das wissen wir noch nicht so genau, wie die Zusammenarbeit da sein kann. Ähm ja und die angucken wollen. Also entweder die man bereits hat,
oder die man gerne hacken will.
Zentralstelle für, oh ich kriege den Namen immer nicht hin, für Informationstechnik Sicherheit, in der Informationstechnologie oder sowas. Ähm, ich ich vergesse den Namen immer wieder, aber,
Genau, da da soll die Hacking Kapazität von der deutschen Bedarfsträger quasi gebündelt werden.
Nee, nee, äh die Darstellung von von Karl war schon ein bisschen anders. Er hatte sehr einen starken Fokus darauf gelegt, dass eben ein Großteil auch Forensek sei. Also er hat sozusagen gerade betont, dass es nicht nur ums Hacking geht, aber.
Das ist klar, dass er das betont, wenn,
ich hab leider mich mit ich hab seine Thesen leider unter drei gehört und muss warten bis er den Stoß nochmal öffentlich.
Na, er hat natürlich dort jetzt auch mit ein paar Journalisten geredet, die dann nach der Veranstaltung auch drüber gesprochen haben, aber äh Podium war natürlich sehr spannend, weil er sich der Öffentlichkeit stellen musste,
und die war relativ kritisch und glaube ist natürlich jemand, der jetzt irgendwie jahrelang in der technischen Abteilung des BND arbeitet nicht unbedingt bekannt, dass er sich sozusagen in einer sehr kritischen Öffentlichkeit stellt, der hatte
ziemlich gleich am Anfang, das erste Mal dann zu sagen, er hatte Publikum angefangen zu lachen. Dann hat er so eine Bemerkung gemacht, dass der Staat keine Massenüberwachung macht und das,
also Publikum.
Publikum, nichts.
Bullshit Level war quasi über über Schritten und also Spionagesoftwares sind die Kriminellen. Das ist nicht was der Staat macht. Also er wollte sich da ganz ganz merkwürdig abgrenzen.
Bionage ist auf einmal nicht mehr das was der Staat macht.
Dort sind die anderen die Kriminellen.
Sag das mal James Bond.
Na ja, es ist halt äh ich kann's verstehen, das ist halt sein, seine, so eine Art wie das als Behördenchef
darstellt, aber er ist dann doch sehr gedrängt worden, mal ein bisschen konkreter zu werden. Vor allen Dingen, wie die Fragen, ich habe ihm eine gewisse Vorlage dafür geliefert, weil er an dem Tag, also vor zwei Tagen hatte die Trump-Regierung gerade angekündigt, dass die
Regeln, die er in den USA bekannt sind, wie die Geheimdienste mit Sicherheitslücken umzugehen haben, auch die Polizeien, dass die überarbeitet werden und äh,
passen werden.
Das ist der Wein Rebilities Equitys Process.
Korrekt. Und wer sozusagen paar Stunden vorher und das habe ich natürlich ähm weil mir das auch wichtig war, sofort mit eingebaut. Wir hatten da so Eingangsstatements
der eigentlichen Diskussion und
da sind dann auch noch mehrere Nachfragen erfolgt. Wir wollten das mal hören. Wird das so ein wird es so eine Regeln geben, wie werden die aussehen? Darf die Öffentlichkeit die mit debattieren
Ja, was machen die? Also, wenn sie Sicherheitslücken finden, wenn sie Exploids kaufen oder sie selber finden.
Wie ist denn da der aktuelle Stand? Also erst haben sie ja wie hieß es ja unter gar keinen Umständen werden wir Exploids kaufen? Das war dann nach einer Woche ja vielleicht müssen wir auch mal ein Exploid kaufen. Ähm was die aber genau machen, also wie die zum Beispiel
ihre Ressourcen verteilen, ne? Die haben wie viele Mitarbeiter wollen sie haben? Ich glaube, sie sind jetzt irgendwie noch mit sehr wenigen.
Na, die mehrere hundert äh am Ende, also.
Sie am Ende haben, aber ich weiß, dass lange Zeit darüber gewitzelt wurde, dass es nur sieben waren.
Tatsächlich hat er hat er auch eingeräumt. Also er sagte aber nee er ist ja hier ein Behördenchef, erstmal muss man so sagen eine gewisse Verwaltung aufbauen, um dann einzustellen zum ersten Dezember, wenn aber jetzt dann auf die ersten eingestellt, die nicht nur Orga machen,
Also da habe ich ein gewisses Verständnis für, er hat sich da so ein bisschen gewehrt, dass sich die Presse über ihn lustig machte sozusagen, weil die kennen Leute finden. Tatsächlich sind sie ja angesiedelt, unmittelbar bei der Bundeswehr, Uni und werden natürlich da auch sicherlich äh
äh rekrutieren.
Wenn da die ein oder andere äh Bachelorarbeit und Masterarbeit vergeben und ähm.
Natürlich ist glaube ich, zieht es für viele kein attraktiver Arbeitgeber. Also ich glaube hier in Deutschland ist einfach immer noch sehr viel Skepsis äh mit
Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten in diesem Bereich. Es ist einfach hier kein, kein No-Brainer wie in den USA oder so. Oder ist das auch keiner mehr,
Also ich fand's schon interessant, dass er hatte das so ein bisschen Rechtfertigungs
hat man auch gemerkt, aber ist jetzt auch nicht also auch nicht jemand, der sich da verkriecht, der hat schon durchaus auch diskutiert. Aber er hatte keine Antworten. Und das Publikum hat's mehrfach verlangt. Die sagt, na ja, wie soll's denn gehen?
hat er aber letztlich dann auch so ein bisschen die Karte gezogen. Wir sind nur Dienstleister. Ähm wir sind wir entscheiden dort auch nicht, wenn dann müsste der Minister da tun und so.
Also als ich ähm primär geht es dabei ja um letztendlich Staatstrojaner,
da na ja, so natürlich ist das gar nicht Fall, als die Debatte vor einem Jahr losging, da hat niemand dieses Wort in den Mund genommen, da und auch hier in dem Artikel den Hakantan Riverdi in der Süddeutschen geschrieben hat über dieses Zusammentreffen, steht's noch irgendwie Deutschlands oberster Code-Knacker,
wo du denkst so, Freunde, niemals werden die äh vernünftig, also werden die von Kryptoanalysefähigkeiten soweit kommen, dass die ernsthaft jetzt,
was knacken können,
Das wäre, das wird einfach nicht dort stattfinden. Ähm die wir, die sind primär darauf ausgelegt, ähm Schwachstellen zu finden, also zu hacken und nicht wirklich,
sage ich jetzt mal, wie ähm hier Blatschleypark, äh Codes zu knacken. Ja, das ist ein,
das ist aber natürlich einerseits so ein bisschen der der Nimbus, den sie haben wollen so, wir sind hier, wir sind hier Touring so, ne? Wir machen.
Oh wow.
Ist doch so und ich ich muss tatsächlich sagen so hier mit diesem äh mit diesem ähm Code-Knacker äh Ding,
Gehen sie in diese Richtung. Der Punkt, der hierbei diskutiert werden muss, ist genau der, den du ansprichst, in Wirklichkeit suchen die Schwachstellen in IT-Systemen. Das Best, die beste Möglichkeit, eine Verschlüsselung zu umgehen, ist den Endpunkt zu infizieren. Deswegen macht man das auch. Und das ist ja, wenn
um zu infizieren braucht man Schwachstellen. Gibt die menschlichen Schwachstellen, okay? Gebt die ungepätschten Schwachstellen und es gibt die unbekannten Schwachstellen. Die Unbekannten sind irgendwie das Problem
Und da meine ich doch auch, das fällt mir jetzt erst auf, als wir die Stellungnahme geschrieben haben zur Staatsregierung in Deutschland. Ist das,
Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, mein turbulentes Jahr, da gab es noch gar nicht diese ganzen One a crise und so.
Na ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, aber die Diskussion gab es ja trotzdem. Also äh wir hatten nur das Beisp.
Die Diskussion gab's natürlich, die haben wir in diese mit der Stellungnahme haben wir ja auch genau da rein. Aber es ist quasi die Stellungnahme war war das Februar oder März.
Ich glaube April oder.
April, also auf jeden Fall vorne.
Ja, aber der war groß, aber wir hatten die Debatte früher schon. Also ich finde nicht, dass dass.
Nein nein, ich meine, die die das Desast, das Desaster wenige Monate später hat dann nochmal
denke ich dem noch mehr Bedeutung gegeben, was wir da geschrieben haben, weil in der ich erinnere mich ja noch in der Anhörung war ich hier mit diesen mehreren Staatsanwälten, mit dem äh BKA ähm,
Vize Hensche und so, das war ja da war das ja noch so ein bisschen
Ja, da können sie mal davon ausgehen, dass wir damit sicher, äh, damit, dass wir damit sicher umgehen mit unseren Schwachstellen und so, da wird
müsste man schon sehr blöd sein, dass das in die Welt geht und na ja, wir haben jetzt ja schon einige Monate in dieser Debatte gesehen, wo eben echt was wo,
Was los ist so? Ich glaube äh einige der One Acrylgeschädigten sehen das inzwischen vielleicht anders.
Nein, nicht nur das. Wir haben auch noch Sushado Brokers, also in der Diskussion, die in den USA auch harsch geführt wird, also dass der, dass die NSA ja offenbar auch nicht in der Lage ist, ihre eigene IT zu schützen
oder aber Insider hat die liegen. Sieht ja so aus, als wenn letzterer der Fall ist. Ähm
Also wir haben vor allen Dingen auch neue Schadensklassen, ne? Deshalb so eine Diskussion, weil die Schadensdumme so unglaublich hoch war. Sie war international und es betraf insbesondere in Großbritannien ja auch äh medizinische Einrichtungen
wir haben hier das erste Mal was Leib und Leben von Menschen bedroht in einer sehr umfänglichen Form, was die Diskussion geändert hat und
äh glaube natürlich äh gewisse gewisse Änderung hat sich auch durch Trump ergeben, weil einfach glaube ich,
in den USA, anders mit den Geheimdiensten umgeht. Also einfach nicht mehr die nicht mehr so sehr als Machtinstrument begreift, sondern also da so ein ganz ambivalentes Verhältnis zwischen Trump und seinen Geheimdiensten herrscht. Da ist einfach weniger
klassische Machtpolitik als früher. Also kommt dazu und ich glaub da ist noch was anderes. Der glaubt dieser IT,
Sicherheitsvertrauenskrise hat sich noch eher verfestigt, ja? Ähm nun sagen die aber natürlich zu sagen mit Hacken,
zieht es nur ein Viertel der Aufgaben, es war so ungefähr die Darstellung, die die er sagte.
Der Rest ist Reisekostenabrechnung, oder?
Nein, na, sie sagen ihm auch, also wir wollen auch Forellensekt machen. Wir wollen Tools sozusagen zur Verfügung stellen. Aber ähm
wie das sozusagen wirklich aufgeteilt wird, hat er natürlich nicht dargelegt, also,
zu sagen, welche Prozentanteil des Personals wat macht. Und natürlich kann man sich auch vorstellen, dass sie auch noch andere Dienstleistungen machen, soweit wie ähm
Okay, ich habe hier ein Telefon, wie komme ich eigentlich sozusagen an die Inhalte, also ganz klassische Dienstleistungen wie äh die jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Schwachstellen im engeren Sinne zu tun haben
Er musste sich heute hart rechtfertigen. Ich glaube nicht, dass äh dass die deutsche Öffentlichkeit sich gefallen lassen sollte, dass die nicht über den Umgang mit Sicherheitslücken reden,
will der Regen haben und will sie auch öffentlich debattieren. Und dafür ist natürlich ein Geheimdienstmann an der Spitze dieser Behörde letztlich eine Frechhei,
finde ich auch nicht akzeptabel, Tabik ihm übrigens auch gesagt, da hat er durchaus glaube ich als legitimes Argument wahrgenommen. Mit Hatik von der für eine Entscheidung, eine politische Entscheidung dort, einen langjährigen BND Mann hinzusetzen und zu sagen
Die Behörde bedient nicht nur Polizeien, sondern bedient auch gleichzeitig die Geheimdienste. Was denn.
Und der es es kam natürlich auch wieder die die komplette Litanei an Diskussion heraus. Er natürlich wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, auch noch gesagt na ja, wenn wir diesen wenn wir jetzt irgendwie äh wenn unsere Partnerdienste,
uns nicht vertrauen können, dann geben die uns keine keine Silberdays mehr, wenn die damit rechnen müssen, dass wir, ne, dass also solche diese gesamte Schiene kommt ja und ich, was ich daran immer so wirklich faszinierend an solchen Gesprächen finde, ist dieses,
Ähm wie diese in Rente,
Diese innere Rente Widerspruch in der Auffassung von was Sicherheit ist, ne? Also das das.
Er hat sehr viel über Sicherheit geredet, aber natürlich stellt er die her aus seiner.
Genau, er meint, er würde, also er, er, er schafft diese ganze Unsicherheit, er sammelt, er braucht die Unsicherheit in der Welt, um für Sicherheit zu sorgen, ne? Und ähm,
Andererseits muss man jetzt auch sagen die sagen die würden über jetzt die von uns vertretene Position sagen die wollen die.
Absolute Sicherheit und werden dadurch nur noch mehr Unsicherheit für uns alle erreichen, ne? Das sind ja so die die beiden äh die beiden Pole der Diskussionen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jemals gelöst werden. Umso wichtiger ist es leider, immer wieder auch diese ermüdenden
Diskussionen zu führen, vor allem in so einer, also der würde jetzt vermuten, dass da wenig da wird jetzt argumentativ inhaltlich nichts Neues für dich dabei gewesen sein.
Na, er hat sich in manchen Dingen sehr klar positioniert, äh in Bezug auf die Verbot von Verschlüsselung, wo er ganz deutlich sozusagen mit mir auch einer Meinung war, dass man Mathematik nicht verbieten kann,
Also das ist ja schon mal eine Aussage, die ist glaube ich tatsächlich äh in der Süddeutschen war das äh glaube ich ganz treffend kommentiert, keine Selbstverständlichkeit relational
und auch, dass man sozusagen nicht nur Schwächung äh von koptographischen Verfahren irgendwie gesetzlich vorschreiben will oder Hintertüren oder so. Das finde ich schon ist eine gute deutsche Position, die ist anders als in anderen Ländern
Also diese die Debatte ist hier zumindest ein mit ein bisschen mehr Gehirn,
geführt. Aber er hat natürlich trotzdem wieder die Alternativen in Frage gestellt. Er hat sie auch konkret mir gestellt, nämlich zu sagen, ja also wenn äh,
ja. Was soll man denn machen sozusagen? Sagen sie doch mal. Das ist immer so ein bisschen ja.
Genau. Ihnen musst du auch nochmal was einfallen daz.
Wie so eine wie war das irgendwie siebziger, achtziger, eben vom Kriegsverweigerer, Tribunal? Stellen sie sich vor, der Russe kommt und knacken sie, hacken sie jetzt den Computer oder nicht.
Na ja, was ist das so ein bisschen? Also diese, ich kann net verstehen, dass seine Denker, ja, aber A ist das nicht meine Rolle, äh mir geht es um die Fragen der der IT-Sicherheit generell, um die Fragen des Kernbereichsschutzes, die mir immer noch zu,
kommen, also die die wirkliche Teams für Menschen, die in den Geräten steckt. Und ist als wenn mich.
Der.
Bereich der privaten Lebens.
Bereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung der grundgesetzlichen Schutz.
Absoluten Schutz zugehen. Ja. Also.
Absolut Scheiße. Aber auch erst durch das äh Urteil des des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Es der ist sozusagen eigentlich mit dem großen Lauschangriff etabliert worden, das war die Wand so im Schlafzimmer. Also wenn man egal wann man Menschen, Menschen
irgendwie verdächtigt oder so, die haben einen Kernbereich, also nicht die Privatsphäre, sondern wirklich den höchstpersönlichen Bereich, wo sie eben mit ihren, mit ihren Partnern reden oder mit einem äh Psychologen oder mit einem Pfarrer oder so. Also wo niemand hineinhorchen darf.
Auch nicht ein bisschen. Aber wenn es wichtig ist.
Na ja, man muss schon.
Sonst nichts eingefallen.
Es ist die die Debatte ist weniger geworden, also ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass dieser Kernrecht nicht mehr so für voll genommen wird. Du musst dir mal vorstellen, weil die sich ja denken, ist so ein irgendwie so ein
bärtigen Fremden, also die sozusagen den Terrorprototyp, der hat keine Intimsphäre. Dem wird auch keine zugebilligt. Also die Debatte ist ja sehr seltsam verzogen, weil ja Menschenrechte für diese Leute ja irgendwie gar nichts mehr gelten,
Das ist ja hat sich wirklich verändert seit dem großen Lauschangriff. Äh,
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich habe auch gerade so ein bisschen so einen Eindruck, jetzt hatte ich vorhin kurz erzählt, da wollen wir aber jetzt nicht so näher drauf eingehen. Es gab jetzt gerade parallel dazu eine sehr interessante Debatte in Deutschland, über vierzig Jahre RF und wie der Staat über die strenge schlug und wie der Terrorismus früher gesehen wurde und wie er heute gesehen wurde und so Zeit
und da bin ich so ein bisschen sicherlich so ein bisschen von beeinflusst, weil sich das eben über die Jahrzehnte verändert hat.
Das ist äh also diese Debatte sich anzuschauen ist sowieso eine der wichtigsten Sachen, die man so mal,
an an irgendwie Vorbildung,
in den Bereich sich einfach mal geben kann. Ich weiß, äh also ich hab das sehr genau verfolgt über mein Einstieg fördert das Buch hier von Stefan Aust,
Bader-Mainhoff-Komplex, das ist schon was, was man mal so also die Debatten, die da stattfinden ähm,
natürlich dann auch im weiteren Verlauf, wenn dann irgendwie äh kommen wir natürlich immer natürlich zu Gerd Baum dann auch irgendwann, ne? Der ähm
zu Raffzeiten, Innenminister war heute vom Bundesverfassungsgericht irgendwie noch die
welche welche wichtigen Bürgerrechtsklagen hat er da alle durchgehauen? Vorratsdatenspeicherung war dabei.
Natürliche PK-Gesetz aber auch das Abschließen von Flugzeugen, ich weiß nicht mehr wie man das nannte.
Ach ja dieses hier Ferdinand von Schirach.
Ja genau, also der ist einfach äh der hat den Gegner mindestens an sieben oder acht äh von den vierzehn Urteilen Anteilen. Und der ist aber vor allen Dingen auch glüblich sehr, also im öffentlichen Diskurs äh da einfach sehr deutlich.
Sehr deutlich, aber also ne, da halt zu sehen, wir haben ja andere Leute in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik gerade so äh Otto Schili. Von dem ja der große Lauschangriff nachher kam, oder? Wenn ich das jetzt richtig.
Ähm, wenn ich das jetzt nicht ein danach äh nein glaube der ist ein danach. Oh, da bin ich jetzt nicht sicher, da würde ich eine Scheiße sagen. Äh ich glaube, das war so ein Vorgänger.
Ich, also es gibt auf jeden Fall den den Otto-Katalog getauften.
Bin mir nicht sicher. Otto Katalog. Ja, die Otto-Konaloge waren ja nach Mandy Leven.
Stimmt natürlich ja klar, der war, das war ja, also das war ja zu Zeiten, ja.
Also ich denke, es war davor, aber der ist trotzdem Prototyp.
Und es gibt halt, es gibt halt net diesen diesen Otto Schili, der alte Raffverteidiger, der jetzt irgendwie dann so die am Ende nochmal alle rechts außen überholt hat.
Nur warte, da ist noch Horst Mahler.
Noch Horst Mahler, der ist äh rechts rübergefallen und dann gibt's den ehemaligen Innenminister Gerd Baum, der heute vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht äh irgendwie zum Schutz der Bürgerrechte klagt. Und dann gibt,
immer nur geradeaus gegangen. Der hat bis jetzt bis zum Ende einfach weiter in die in die Richt.
Vielleicht können wir es verlinken, äh weil eine Aufzeichnung gab in Babel.
Echt? Ja, bitte, unbedingt verlinken.
Im Babylon-Kino war eine Veranstaltung, wo sozusagen die drei Seiten vertreten waren. Test Baum
Als ehemaliger Innenminister und auch wirklich, also er hat auch durchaus den Staat vertreten, denn Ströbele als auch äh damals Rechtsanwälte und Verteidiger und die ehemalige RF Terroristin äh Silke Meyer-Witt, die äh sehr interessante Einblicke gegeben hat, wie man
zu derzeit Terrorist wurde, bietet aus dem Innenleben der etwa ein war wirklich sehr interessant.
es gibt eine Aufzeichnung bei Radio eins, weil ich weiß und Spiegel war, also Spiegel DE war der Sponsor, aber ob die eine Aufzeichnung hinstellen, weiß ich nicht, die hatten einen Stream.
Okay. Machen wir, werden.
Ich darf das sehr empfehlen. Äh denn ich glaube in dieser Form werden die nicht mehr oft zusammenkommen. Das wird ja jetzt langsam Geschichte. Also so richtig Geschichte.
Jede alle zehn Jahre wer dann nochmal hier die äh die Leute von der von der Landshut rausgeholt. Das ist jetzt drei.
Da haben sie auch intensiv drüber gesprochen. Also mein Bussi, ich meine, die Protagonisten sind natürlich jetzt alle siebzig, achtzig Jahre alt. Ja und insofern weiß man immer, dass es da so langsam Geschichte wird, weil wenn die Teilnehmer werden einfach oder also sind einfach schon sehr alt.
Fällt mir übrigens eigentlich für letztens äh Lufthansa äh eins acht eins geflogen. Das war die Flugnummer der der Landshut. Ähm habe ich auch gedacht, äh dass sie nicht genug äh dass sie nicht genug Flugnummern haben, dass sie so eine.
Äh jetzt haben wir das so erwähnt, also man kann glaube ich nicht voraussetzen, dass die heutige Generation noch so richtig weiß, was Landshut ist. Das müssten wir jetzt vielleicht verlinken oder so. Also die Landshut war ein entführtes äh ja mit äh,
über äh glaube einundneunzig äh oder einundachtzig oder einundneunzig äh normalen Torsten, also Menschen. Das war sowieso der Zeitpunkt, wo die RF
ihre Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung eingebüßt hat, weil.
Ja, zusammen mit äh Captain, Merthyra, Machmut, äh also mit einem äh Palästinenser.
Und dem Selektieren von Juden. Äh ich glaube, da da ist die Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung äh ganz deutlich.
Die wollten damit mit der Flugzeugeentführung frei pressen, äh die Gefangenen, die politischen Gefangenen in Stammheim, Andreas Bader,
Rücke Mainhof, äh Gudrun Enzlin und äh der eine war schon tot.
Bianca Raspe. Ne, Jankar Raspe war da glaube ich auch noch.
Ja, also so lange her, alles sehr spannend, wir haben die.
Ja, wir wir werden's verlinken.
Kommen wir zum Hauptteil der Geschichte heute,
denn vier Jahre Snowden heißt auch, äh dass der EGMR sich jetzt endlich mal eine Anhörung rausgelassen hat in der Klage,
Zusammen mit mehreren Organisaten, das ist so lange her, dass es also es ist das hat mich immer mal wieder auch wirklich auf dem kalten Fuß erwischt, dass ich gefragt wurde, hör mal, ist da eigentlich draus geworden.
Ne, es gab aber auch mehrere, die musste auch auseinander. Also ist ja nicht mehr so einfach, die alle zu äh genau.
Deswegen erklär doch nochmal genau, um welche es hier ging.
Ein Captain zusammengetan mit äh drei britischen Organisationen. Äh das war schon Ende zweitausenddreizehn, also vor mehr als vier Jahren, also ungefähr fast genau jetzt vier Jahren. Und.
Also wenige Monate nach der nach der Werdung.
Da war natürlich Prison und Tempore schon bekannt und es gab schon eine Menge Diskussionen, aber da fehlt natürlich vieles, von dem war dann erst zweitausendvierzehn, fünfzehn und sechzehn rauskamen. Aber zu sagen, der der Schritt nach Straßburg,
ziehen ohne den innerbritischen irgendwie Instanzenweg da hoch zu gehen den hatten wir schon Ende zweitausenddreizehn beschlossen und sind drei Organisationen. Das äh die Human Wit,
Watch? Nee, er quatscht die ähm Open Ride Scroop. Oh, ich bin schon ganz verwirrt. Die äh tatsächlich sind's. Genau.
Privacy International.
Nein, das ist nicht mein Fall, ja.
Es ist katastrophal.
Ich bin jetzt grad selber verwirrt, also Big Brother Watch, Open Right,
und die Schriftstellervereinigung Pen sind die ursprünglichen drei Beschwerdeführer, die mit mir zusammen als vierte Beschwerdeführerin den Fall ins Laufen gebracht haben und als erster sozusagen nach Straßburg gebracht haben. Aber mittlerweile sind wir, glaube ich,
siebzehn verschiedene äh NGOs, weil sie eben andere Fälle dazugezogen haben und da sind die von dir genannt und alle bei.
Okay, also.
Äh wir müssen das selber auseinander halten.
So, jetzt habt ihr ähm jetzt habt ihr, wogegen habt ihr euch denn die wogegen hat sich die Beschwerde denn zweitausenddreizehn gerichtet.
Äh die ist äh im Januar zweitausendvierzehn beim Jeng hat sich gerichtet gegen die Massenüberwachung der britischen Geheimdienste, gegen ein
Kontrollregime in Großbritannien, was sollen Namen nicht verdient und auch gegen die Art wie die Überwachungsoperation ähm,
wie die genehmigt werden, also die Regeln dafür und letztlich gegen Reper, das ist sozusagen Gesetz. Ähm was die ähm,
was die Möglichkeiten dieser Berechtigung verschriftlicht. Mittlerweile ist es nicht mehr aktuell gibt ein Neut-Gesetzinvestigatories Powers ähm sozusagen,
Act, genau.
Dass Gerichte das IPT Investigatoric Power Stribional.
Na, das sind innerbritische Gericht, das haben wir nicht angerufen, wir haben's gerade übersprungen.
Ich dachte, war nicht das ist nicht das IPT, das, was auch die Genehmigungen erteilt oder ist das nur der.
Nee, die Genehmigung in Großbritannien werden erteilt von einem Minister im Kabinett, also Secretaria State. Im Wesentlichen wartet Theresa May damals.
Okay und.
Auch kein Richter drauf wird, ist äh in dem britischen Gericht sozusagen das nicht vorgesehen, dass da ein Richter draufguckt.
Das wird einfach gemacht. Das äh hat sich einfach als effizienter wahrscheinlicher raus.
Na man muss halt schon Grund nennen und sie haben auch verschiedene Gründe, die das sein können, aber da ist halt eben so geregelt, dass das eine wie eine Art Ministererlaub Erlaubnis ist. Und sie ist eigentlich auch,
Also sie ist quasi dauerhaft, das die Richter nannten
äh das ist ein Zitat, Recycling. Also diese Berechtigungen werden halt äh immer fortverlängert, sodass sie am Ende dauerhaft sind,
Dagegen haben wir uns gewehrt, also wenn wenn wir ein Urteil in unserem Fall bekommen, was sozusagen dem zustimmt, dann,
Gesetz rechtswidrig. Aber mittlerweile gibt's halt auch schon wieder neue.
Wie das so ist. Diese drei Organisationen sind alle britisch. Wie kommt da äh noch eine deutsche Person mit dazu? Also welcher.
Na ja, es ist eine gewisse strategische Überlegung, weil natürlich äh wenn man nach Straßburg
zum europäischen Menschenrechtsgerichtshof, dann richtet man ja sozusagen mit der mit der Rechtsgrundlage seine Beschwerde aufgrund der äh Menschenrechtskonvention, der EU-Menschenrechtskonvention und da ist es natürlich nicht verkehrt
verschiedene europäische ja Linien anzugucken und ich bin nun mal Deutsch
Und der anderen Briten und so war das eine gewisse strategische Entscheidung. Weil das eben eine europäische Menschenrechtskonvention ist. Aber wir haben natürlich jetzt
äh dadurch, dass sie die anderen Fälle hinzugekommen sind, auch sowieso nochmal einen anderen Skope. Denn die anderen haben teilweise andere Beschwerden. Die sind teilweise direkt betroffen, die haben später ihre Namen, also der Organisation, wie zum Beispiel im Andisty, direkt in den äh
nodenfalls gefunden, die haben halt Kunden also nochmal eine andere Art von Betroffenheit zeigen. Mhm. Insofern war für uns dann leichter zu äh ähm
Werde zusammenzuziehen und zu zu sagen, ja, also bei der Betroffenheit, also ob man wirklich selber von dieser Überwachung betroffen ist, ist das relativ leicht zu zei.
Wenn es in den Zornfalls drinsteht.
Sie haben die auch direkt bemängelt. Die anderen sind aber alle über den von dir erwähnte IPT, also den Investigatory Power Stribune, ein britisches Geheimgericht erst gegangen. Deswegen zog sie alle zu.
Das habe ich dann, ah ey, das ist so.
Ja, es ist auch kompliziert.
Weil ich erinnere mich an diese IPT-Geschichten, dass wir da äh dass wir das immer noch diskutiert hatten, aber das war okay ein anderer anderer Fluss. So jetzt,
Vier Jahre Pass, vier Jahre seit oder annähernd vier Jahre seit eurer Initialen Einreichung. Dann kommen paar andere mit dazu, es werden neue Sachen, kommen neue Snowden, Fights raus, ihr ihr gebt die mit in die Akten oder,
neue Organisationen kommen dazu, beziehungsweise die Fälle werden zusammengelegt oder die Beschwerden werden zusammengelegt und dann irgendwann kriegst du Post äh hier, Frau Kurz übrigens Montag, Straßburg.
Ja, äh wir waren, nee, ähm wir waren natürlich erfreut, weil die Anhörung sehr, sehr selten sind und weil es tatsächlich total selten, also die nehmen auch nicht viele Beschwerden an, wie im beim Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe, aber noch viel seltener gibt's da mündliche Anhörung,
Da waren wir sehr erfreut und bringt natürlich auch eine Form von Öffentlichkeit. Also die britische Regierung muss dahingehen und sich auch rechtfertigen, was sie auch getan hat,
Und das ist natürlich interessant und außerdem lernst du dann noch was anderes ähm nämlich, wenn die,
Richter Fragen stellen, wohin deren Kritik eigentlich geht. Jetzt Verfahren lief er über mehrere Jahre schriftlich und du hast ja da Argumente, die ausgetauscht werden, aber die Richter, das war die große Kammer, also zehn Richter äh haben auch,
Tatsächlich konkrete mündliche Fragen gestellt und dann siehst du natürlich so.
Weißt du was sie interessiert.
Klar, also ähm es ist halt äh für mich war das auch nochmal spannend, weil ich natürlich an diesem Gerichtshof noch nie war. Ich konnte nicht wissen, wie sozusagen der Ablauf.
Weil das gibt's ja nicht konstanz. Wer bist du jetzt irgendwie Anfang dreißig? Da warst du an diesem Gerichtshof noch nicht, ja? Das ist ja so, als wär's, als hättest du Australien noch nicht bereist.
Nein, nein, also man lernt ja immer was, wenn man solche, also.
Der IGR, das ist halt echt Mann. Also okay. Man muss dazu sagen, du warst wie oft am Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Fünf Mal jetzt,
Aber dabei gehen die Beschwerde für, da war ich ja immer nur als Sachverständiger. Und auch beim Europäischen Gerichtshof als Sachverständige und nicht als Beschwerdeführerin. War natürlich auch nochmal eine andere Rolle. Ähm,
Also ich bin, ich bin ja kein, ich habe, ich habe ja keine besondere Expertise im britischen Recht oder so. Ähm dafür haben wir natürlich auch die Anwälte, die sehr erfahren waren, also die auch andere Menschenrechtsfälle äh krasse Fälle, also auch Drohnenfälle und so, also
die sind sehr erfahren. Das war manchmal für mich schwer zu folgen, also ich habe manchmal an diesen Papieren sehr geknabbert bei den in britischer
rechtlich korrekter Sprache sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und wir hatten auch Hotelkurs. Oh, das war teilweise, also es ist war schon äh intellektuell herausfordernd.
Dann waren die halten die Barris da hatten die dann auch alle ihre weißen Perücken an und.
Äh tatsächlich hätte einer eine äh du musst ja so einen bestimmten Status haben als äh britischer Anwalt, um überhaupt so eine Mütze tragen zu dürfen,
Also da gibt's ja so eine Hierarchie und da waren welche bei, aber da wurde das Protokoll nicht, die hatten auch keine Roben an, die Anwälte und nicht die Vertreter der Brit.
Weil die diesen, also weil die.
Die machen können, haben sie sich aber dagegen entschieden? Wer hätte X ja lustig hier,
Bei zwei davon hatten so eine Mützen. Also so eine ja, so eine, wie heißen die denn richtig? Perücken.
Verrücke, ja, also irgendwie so eine.
Leider haben sie uns das nicht gegeben. Das fand ich ja doch ein bisschen schade, ja.
Schade. Schade, Elter.
Die Richter hatten natürlich ihre Romen.
Für wahrscheinlich haben die wollten die einfach nicht äh besser gekleidet sein als die Richter.
Ich glaube, wenn man nicht muss, äh wird man vielleicht nicht unbedingt, ich weiß ich.
Ja und es ist wahrscheinlich äh hätte das jetzt auch vielleicht zu dem in der Brexit-Konnutation irgendwie blöd ausgesehen vorm EGMR, habe da mit seinem Coach, also weiß gepudert aufzutreten.
Aber tatsächlich kriegt man Hinweise. Also die äh legen Wert auf äh formate Kleidung gibt, sagen sie dir auch schriftlich. Also du sollst ja halt nicht mit Jeans kommen so. Das ist schon die hatten wir schon relativ strenge Regeln, die sehen. Ja, die sagen.
Dresscode. Wir laden sie ein zur Anhörung im Fall siebzehn NGOs gegen die britische Regierung, Dresscode, Business Casual, danach.
Ne, die haben noch andere Regeln. Zum Beispiel die Türen sind ja so wirklich zu, da ist aber kein, also die Türen werden geschlossen, da fehlt auch jemand, der die Tür bewacht. Da gibt keinen raus und reingehen. So, no. Also, besuchen sie vorher die Toiletten,
Also.
Rasseln mit im Popcorn.
Und keiner o.
Dann in die Hose macht irgendwie, dann steht man da oder wat.
Sie haben einen sehr direkte Zeitregime und gab auch eine Pause, aber es gab auch keine Aufzeichnung. Also die Leute haben wir haben alle auf Papier geschrieben. Also und die Anwälte hatten.
War nicht erlaubt und zwar.
Kein Computer.
Und die Anmelder kannst dir vorstellen, wie wir die dann mitschleppen, nehmen, weil sich ganz viel Papier dahin geschlepp,
Ich denke, es hat damit, also es gibt ja eine Aufzeichnung, die wird auch am selben Tag,
ähm dann veröffentlicht, also die haben schon eine eine sehr gute Art äh Aufzeichnung auch wegen der Übersetzung, die haben so Übersetzungskabinen wie beim OGH,
aber ich glaube die wollen gewisse Kulturen des des rechtlichen Dialoges beibehalten. Deswegen haben die auch so strikte Zeitregimes
Und die wollen natürlich keine direkten Aufzeichnungen, weil sie ja wenige, wenige Stunden später den Stream dann als Video.
Ach so, also sie stellen einen nachher eine bereit, okay.
Das machen sie, das fand ich auch sehr sinnvoll. Äh und du kannst halt die Dokumente oder einen Großteil der Dokumente auf jeden Fall auch haben. Äh sie wollen aber nicht, dass du in der Zeit sozusagen direkt fitterst.
Kein kein Facebook Live.
Haben natürlich welche gemacht? Also.
Alter Vater, der muss auch äh.
Musst du schon mutig sein. Aha, wenn du Pech hast, wirst du vor der Tür gesetzt, aber das haben welche gemacht, aber tatsächlich sehr wenige.
Ja, ist vielleicht auch ne, ja.
Na gut und ey die vier Stunden bist du komplett ansehen kannst ist glaube ich jetzt auch vertret.
Ich kann andererseits natürlich auch verstehen, dass jetzt so wahrscheinlich ein NGO-Vertreter, der dahinten sitzt und den Twitter-Account hat und sagt, das ist einer der wichtigsten Tage.
Exakt so war das auch.
Und dann twitterst du halt irgendein Bild und sagst, wir sind hier gerade im.
Na, vor allen Dingen Text, also die die bestimmte Aussagen geht ja in die geht nicht so sehr um Bilder, geht vor allen Dingen um bestimmte zugespitzte Aussagen, die da fallen.
Dann schießte das dadurch wirst halt Zitatgeber für die Presse und äh.
Aber die saß natürlich auch da, also also wir waren auch ein paar deutsche Journalisten da.
Ich meine jetzt die die zu Hause sitzt Journalisten, die die am die Browserjournalisten.
Na daran habe ich auch durchaus ein Interesse. Ich glaube, dass der Fall nicht erfolgreich sein kann, wenn man die diese öffentliche Diskussion auch nicht herstellt.
So erfolgreich, was passiert, wenn das äh was ist der der potenziell erwartbare Erfolg, der da erreicht werden kann.
Na, die Briten haben ja schon in den Fünfzigern, die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention ratifiziert und sind daran gebunden. Also das Urteil wirkt unmittelbar. Tatsächlich haben die Briten auch äh ganz erstaunlich äh für mich jedenfalls habe ich auch erst
gelesen wusste gar nicht. Äh ähm tatsächlich besser als alle anderen europäischen Länder, die Urteile umgesetzt. Ich fande bemerkenswert. Ähm,
Im konkreten Fall heißt das natürlich nur, dass das Gesetz damit menschenrechtswidrig wäre oder Teile davon ähm und das sind eventuell Auswirkungen hat öfters derzeit bestehende Gesetz, weil da gibt's natürlich einen Zusammenhang, weil einige Regeln sind ähnlich
Und je nachdem wie das Urteil ausfällt, würdet sich auswirken auf die aktuelle Gesetzgebung auch.
Und wie, welche Con, also welche Konsequenz hat das dann? Also.
Meine Hoffnung ist ja größer. Also ich möchte natürlich, dass der äh europäische Menschenrechtsgerichtshof hat er schon mal getan hat in anderen Fällen. Ganz konkret, was zur Massenüber, was rum sagt,
Also die Positionen sind natürlich absolut konträr, wir haben eine britische Regierung, die sagt, wir wollen auf, wir werden auf jeden Fall diese Art der Massenüberwachung beibehalten, denn wir sehen es gar nicht als Überwachung,
mit der Daten ist Chicken Shat, wollen wir haben. Wir wollen auch diesen, den diesen größer werdenden Haufen
technisch bearbeiten, im Sinne der Fetterung, Musterentdeckung und so weiter, das haben die sehr, sehr klar gemacht, geht um Discovery, entdecken von von Mustern in diesen La,
und wir haben sozusagen die äh die andere Seite, die.
Diese.
Ja, fünfzehn, sechzehn äh Menschenrechtsgruppen, die einfach sagen, das hat einen Wert, wir haben ein Grundrecht auf Achtung der Privatsphäre, dazu gehören diese Kommunikationsdaten und im Übrigen sind sie auch noch extrem schlecht kontrolliert und vieles davon ist einfach eine Ermessensentscheidung der Geheimdienstler selber. Und das ist ein ganz
grundsätzliche Positionen, die der also Gegenposition, die der Gerichtshof damit natürlich klären kann.
Du hast,
Gerade wir haben eingangs über wie sich die Sprachregelung geändert hat, gesprochen. Ist das in Großbritannien auch so gewesen? Haben die auch so eine ähm Veränderung über die Zeit oder haben die groß haben die das eh schon immer so gesehen?
Und haben immer schon so darüber.
Mein Eindruck war, dass die britische Regierung sehr, sehr offensiv auch betreibt, also zu sagen,
Wir vertreten nicht nur diese Heuhaufenideologie, wir müssen das ganze Heu auf dem Haufen machen, um die Nadel überhaupt zu finden,
schon dazu ist ja ein großer Unterschied, äh auch zudem mal zuletzt äh der europäische Gerichtshof im Leben war zweitausendsechzehn gesagt hat, zur zur Vorortseitensprechung, sondern dass sie eben auch noch sehr stark diese, wir wollen diese riesen Datensätze ähm
auch nach Musterndurchsuchen können. Also,
der Vertreter der britischen Regierung, der hieß James Edi, Discovery nannte, das war sehr deutlich. Das ist schon ist eine andere Position, als es hier üblicherweise vertreten würde und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen so ein Ideologiewechsel, der noch weiter normalisiert, wenn du über Meterdaten redest.
der hat einfach gar keinen Wert. Die sehen das gar nicht als Privatsphäre relevant. Und dass dass da der Menschenrechtsgerichtshof prinzipiell.
Bremsen einbaut, finde ich schon wichtig, aber auch die Parlamentarische Kontrolle. Also äh viele entscheiden, die einfach, wie sie Bock haben, die hatten da so Fragen gestellt, wie,
der Innenrichter sagte, na ja, sie haben ja jetzt ja auch dann physische Abhöreinrichtungen, da wo die Kabel anlanden, da geht's ja vor allen Dingen auch um äh die den transatlantischen Verkehr, den die da abzapfen. Also Fulltake,
Da sagt er,
wer guckt da eigentlich drauf? Also wer ist denn in den physischen Abhöreinrichtungen? Wer wer kümmert sich denn darum? Ist da jemand? Guckt da mal jemand, wer da zusammen den Knopf umlegt? Irgendwie haben sehr konkrete Fragen gestellt oder
die haben auch Clouddaten, die die zu sagen abgreifen, wenn wir über Clouddaten reden, sind da auch die Bilder und Dokumente dabei, die sozusagen die haben da sehr konkrete Fragen gestellt,
Und meine Hoffnung ist schon.
Haben die auch sehr konkrete Antworten bekommen?
Ja, das hatten die leider, da muss ich jetzt mal sagen, das hatte ich so nicht erwartet, hatten die sehr merkwürdige Macht äh vom Ablauf ist es so. Es gibt eine ganz, ganz kurze Begrüßung,
Und dann sagt der, der britische Vertreter zuerst war, der das sehr konfrontativ gesagt hat und am Ende also zurückgewiesen hat, dann sind die Vertreter der Beschwerdeführer, aber nur zwei, wir mussten uns ja doch irgendwie einigen, wer für alle spricht, die sehr unterschiedliche Dinge vorbringen
Und dann war da so ein Aspekt äh von unserer generellen Beschwerde und einen Aspekt vom Datengeheimdienst, Datentauschränk. Und dann,
Haben die Richter angefangen, Fragen zu stellen, aber das war kein Dialog, sondern ein so ein Richter von den Zehen haben sehr konkrete Fragen gestellt, teilweise,
Aus sehr unterschiedlichen Bereichen der Beschwerden. Also nach den Berechtigungen, nach den Abhöreinrichtungen, nach den Clouddaten. Nach der parlamentarischen Kontrolle, nach allem möglicher, also ich habe das Cap Seitenweise geschrieben und dann haben sie gesagt,
Jetzt machen wir eine halbe Stunde Pause und danach beantworten wir die mal,
Kannst du dir vorstellen, was da für eine Panik losbrach? Dann haben natürlich beide Seiten versucht, war ungefähr fünfzehn komplexe Fragen,
richtet wirklich komplexe Fragen auch also unterschiedlichen rechtlichen und technischen Gehalts,
in einer halben Stunde, wo du aber noch runterlaufen musst in deinen Raum irgendwie, du hast ja letztlich bloß nur noch zwanzig Minuten übrig irgendwie vorzubereiten.
Und dann ging sie wieder hoch und dann hatten sie aber sehr wenig Zeit,
Also ich habe nicht verstanden, was es bringen soll, weil du äh weil du hast ganz wenig Erkenntnisse, wenn äh weil natürlich Ala ist eine Selektion,
Trete der britischen Regierung, wollte auch manche Fragen auch nicht antworten. Und konnte auch nicht, die sagen ja dann auch, das ist geheim. Und der hat nur in wenigen.
Man eigentlich auch mal als Verteidiger, also hier als Verteidiger gegen Grundrechte. Wieso werden da die Grundrechte geplus geheim? Wenn man dann immer durchkämme, ne.
Ist Teil Teil der Beschwerde ist auch, dass man, dass man viele von den Regularien gar nicht verstehen kann, sie fehlen oder sie sind geheim und dass man sich dagegen nicht wehren kann. Also das ist auch Teil der der Beschwerde
Aber ich war ja so ein bisschen überrascht, war auch relativ kurz. Dann die Zeit, um auf diese vielen Fragen zu antworten. Also ging offenbar nur um die Fragen. Weil darum.
Die Fragen dann schon auch auf Papier bekommen in dieser Pause.
Nee. Nein, nein, ich habe sie nur.
Man musste sich die akustisch merken oder was.
Na ja, du kannst natürlich später die Aufzeichnungen sehen, da sind die ja auch drauf, aber.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment, wo du es beantworten musst, ist das ja wohl für Gaga.
Fand ich auch und viele also ich fand das fanden übrigens auch die Anwälte. Das sind natürlich dann anderen ist man auch eine große Gruppe, alle da runter in den Raum und haben versucht die zu sortieren und zu welchem will man noch schnell was äh reagieren? Ich war total extrem anspruchsvoll.
Also es war jetzt das heißt sie die haben einfach gesagt, das ist das, was uns interessiert. Und dann haben sie die nachher wieder runtergerattert und dann konnte jeder sagen, Herr Lehrer, ich weiß was, hier ist mein.
Das war schon also als wir zurückkamen, das war auch alles sehr pünktlich, also tatsächlich nach einer halben Stunde, die haben da auch so eine Prozedur wie in Karlsruhe, dann kommt da jemand und sagt sehr laut, eine Kuh und dann kommt die alle rausgelaufen wie in Karlsruhe auch, äh war also ziemlich getimed und dann,
Na, ist ja Frau Frankreich.
Okay.
Also wie bei uns bei uns, also der Taschbundesverfassungsgericht oder kommen die raus und da haben die auch so eine Prozedur. Also.
In den USA ist es Rice oder würde auch sagen, nein voneinander. Ja, okay.
Nee, ich habe mal so eine Glocke, die stehen dann schon alle. Also es gibt schon diese typischen Traditionen. Und dann redet äh im Prinzip,
der Vertreter der britischen Regierung James EDI hat dann angefangen diese Fragen zu adressieren hat dann sozusagen den Richter der die jeweils gestellt hat benannt aber er ist natürlich auch teilweise,
Also er ist auch sehr unfreundlich geworden, der hat ja ein,
der ein Richterin im Prinzip mit ihr geben, was sie zu blöd ist zu verstehen, worum es geht. Also die hat eine Frage auch sehr brüst zurückgewiesen, ja? Das ist hier gar nicht der Scope und also der war teilweise sehr konfrontativ und unfreundlich. Gut.
und der hat natürlich auch für sich versucht, um Teile da so rumzubogen, aber das war ja auch leicht, weil zu viele Fragen. Aber er hat alle irgendwie angesprochen,
in relativ kurzer Zeit. Also ich ich vor allen Dingen, also ich war echt am Schwitzen. Ich hatte,
wolltet ihr auch mitschreiben, um mir eine Meinung bilden und später ja auch äh wir haben ja später auch darüber geredet. Also ich meine, das ist ja der Kern, du redest ja dann nachher mit den Anwenden und versuchst herauszufinden, wohin geht deren Kritik und so. Also es ist für eine intellektuelle Anstrengung.
Was meinst du, wer da jetzt besser weggekommen ist.
Äh ganz klar wir, also die Beschwerdeführer gehen's deutlich, die Richter waren,
wenn die die haben nicht nur den Fall priorisiert, also sie haben ihn angenommen, priorisiert, eine mündliche Anhörung gemacht ist schon klar, dass sie in vielen Punkten uns folgen,
Die Frage ist in welchen und äh wie stark ihr Votum ausfällt. Ich habe keine Zweifel, dass das in in Teil, in dem wir da gewinnen. Und ich bin auch stolz drauf, weil weil,
letztlich ist das alles entstanden aus lauter Spenden. Leute haben äh vor vier Jahren äh die sagen die Kohle zusammengebracht, diese Anwälte zu bezahlen. Das sind ja alle auch NGOs, die drei, die nicht gerade an Geld schwimmen, das sind also Non-Profits,
auch verhältnismäßig kleiner NGOs. Also jetzt die drei,
pen. Äh Big Brother Watch und die Open White Scoop sind jetzt auch nicht die Schlachtrosser, wie zum Beispiel Privace International oder die Aglo ist auch die Aklo ist jetzt dabei,
oder äh änderst die, sondern sind der doch eher kleiner. Ich bin da auch stolz auf das wird letztlich eine Menge Europäer waren. Wir wissen ja auch ungefähr, wo die Zahlungen so herkommen, aus halb Europa oft viele kleine Beträge, ich finde das gut, die Leute,
äh zweitausendvierzehn, Anfang zweitausendvierzehn war auch noch viel mehr Empörung und wir konnten das sozusagen auch umsetzen und da wird ein Urteil kommen.
Wie viel Geld ist denn da zusammengekommen seiner Zeit.
Na, wir hatten damals irgendwie kalkuliert, äh das war so ungefähr, na so um die fünfundzwanzig oder dreißigtausend Pfund brauchen für die für alle Anwälte und sozusagen gesamte Buzzidings, da sind ja auch noch äh Amikosbriefe bei und so,
Weil der bei diesem Gericht geht ähm wir wussten natürlich nicht, dass es sich über vier Jahre zieht. Wir haben ja gedacht, nach der Priorisierung, das wird relativ schnell über die Bühne gehen,
Aber das war natürlich noch nicht so. Und wir haben jetzt nochmal eine nach äh also uns fehlten jetzt tausendzweihundert Pfund. Das war aber im Wesentlichen tatsächlich die Reisekosten, weil ja die die Briten dann noch anreisen mussten.
Fehlen dir immer noch, nee, das musste man ja immer kurz twittern.
Brauchen wir nicht, weil FIFA hat dankenswerterweise darauf hingewiesen und danach waren die tausendzweihundert Pfund da,
muss ich auch mich echt beenden. Also bedanken, die haben die zusammengebracht. Was ich was mich sehr erfreut. Also das war aber auch nur,
die sind jetzt auch kenne, also die haben da nicht im Ritzebahn achtet oder was, das sind ganz normale, sehr aktivistische Menschenrechtsanwälte, die auch super sympathisch, ich hätte die ja immer noch am Telefon. Ähm,
Ja und die haben auch sehr gut plädiert. Äh weil wir so überzeugend, die haben also echt den Menschenrechtsfighter aufgemacht und gesagt,
wenn man nicht weiterführen würde, also auch unsere Demokratie untermindet und warum.
Du hast äh du warst quasi nur dort, du hast jetzt also du hast da nicht gesprochen, ne? Oder.
Ich hätte das wohl können, man kann als Beschwerde äh ähm Führer soweit äh also so ein Rederecht irgendwie so kriegen, er hätte das A nicht gemacht
weil wir so viele Fälle waren und so knappe Zeit war und weil ich auch nicht glaube, dass ich äh da geht's ja nicht um persönliche Betroffenheit, ja, sondern da möchte ich, dass die Anwälte.
Die Anwälte den die wenigen Minuten.
Hätte mir das doch nicht zugetraut. Also weil ich glaube, da haben einfach die zwei Anwärte, die wir dann von dem ganzen Team ausgesucht haben, die alle repräsentiert haben, unglaublich gute und noch erfahrene Anwälte da, echt abgeliefert,
Also und sie haben's auch gut gemacht gegenüber diesem etwas kolerischen äh britischen Vertreter, ja, der da auch so ein bisschen staatsmännisch versucht hat, aufzutreten und dann sehr konfrontativ, weil die haben das.
Das ist natürlich, wenn du das, wenn du das Glück hast, dass da, dass da jemand kolerisch auftritt, dass gut am Ende werden die Richter dann nicht nach äh nach Sympathie entscheiden, aber ähm.
Also mir ich wollte das natürlich auch, ich wollte wissen zu sagen, welche Argumente kommen da auf den Tisch? Ich wollte da unbedingt hinfahren, aber da hätte ich natürlich im Prinzip nicht müssen. Aber ich habe natürlich dann noch ein bisschen mit der Presse geredet und so. Also ich bin nicht,
bin dann schon in dem Sinne zielgerichtet. Ich möchte ja dafür eine Öffentlichkeit herstellen und habe gemacht. Et war aber im Wesentlichen, muss ich sagen, britische Presse.
Passiert da jetzt nochmal was? Also.
Als Termin.
Einfach so nee, das Gericht zieht sich jetzt zurück, weil es ja schon auch irgendwie ein bisschen äh auffällig, wenn man, wenn da jetzt vier Jahre quasi nichts passiert, obwohl das ein Eilverfahren ist.
Nee, da ist eine Menge. Also wir hatten ja die ganze Zeit Schriftverkehr wie Blöde, also das ist ja ein schriftliches Verfahren. Doch es wurde halt nur mehr als wir erwartet hatten.
Und dann sitzt sie und jetzt war da einmal diese Anhörung, das waren jetzt zwei Stunden oder was,
mit einer halben Stunde Pause drin oder so. Und ähm und jetzt sagen die, wir melden uns John Call Ass, äh, Wear Call You.
Na die haben so Erfahrungswerte, die wissen ungefähr, wie lange das immer dauert, wenn die große Kammer eine Anhängung macht und so und ähm sie wird aber es gibt kein, ist nicht wie mit dem äh äh Verfassungsgericht liest niemand vor,
fand ich ja doch ein bisschen enttäuschend, ehrlich gesagt. Nein, die haben keine Verlesung, wie man das bei uns kennt, aber kriegt man ein Urteil teilweise vor, diesen haben die nicht, ist dann das wird versendet.
Komm mit der Post.
Aber das gibt's dann zumindest äh auf Papier. Ist ja schon mal was. Im Gegensatz zu den Fragen.
Ja, nee, aber also nee, nee, ich glaube, die Verlesung in Karlsruhe hat eine Menge zu tun damit, wie die Öffentlichkeit etwahrnimmt. Eine Menge. Ich halte diese.
Klar, du hast, du hast, du hast dann den du hast die die drei Minuten drei Sekunden Ausschnitt in der Tagesschau, wie die.
Herren da, Damen da reinkommen und.
Prozedere.
Mit ihren lustigen Kostümen und dann dann stehen alle auf und dann.
Er hat auch eine Spannung.
Ein Verfassungsorgan und dann hast du auch nochmal alle Beklagten und Kläger irgendwie in Abendgarderobe.
Na, meistens kommen immer nur die Kläger, ne? Also die Ministerien in Deutschland kommen mehr so selten,
Die holen sich so ungern ihre Urteile ab.
Wirklich. Warum nur.
Ich find's ein bisschen schade einfach, weil äh der ist schon sehr angesehen, der Gerichtshof. Und ich glaube, das macht halt einfach äh für Europa einen Unterschied, aber das wird dann unsere,
Schlagkraft seiten, das wird nur die Leute bringen, aber dadurch, dass wir jetzt auch so viele sind und so großer NGOs dabei sind, habe ich eigentlich keinen Zweifel, dass wir das auch unter die Leute bring.
Ja, nee, natürlich.
Und da geht's auch um die Interpretation. Also ich meine, jeder wird das Urteil wieder anders lesen, ne? Oder werden wir schon noch zu tun haben mit.
Ja und äh Zeitlights äh Anfang nächsten Jahres oder was.
Ja, wir gehen davon aus, dass es im Früh ähm Frühjahr oder Frühsommer kommt.
Und eine weitere, also eine weitere Sitzung nach Verhandlungen oder so weiter wird's nicht geben. Das war's jetzt sozusagen.
Das war jetzt mündliche Prüfung. Jetzt aber ey, kommt mir komisch vor.
Ne, du musst aber sehen, irgendwie ist jetzt der, der die fährt eine Menge, das ist ja ein Schrif,
üblicherweise sind überhaupt nur schriftlich, musst du unbedenken. Also, dass wir die mögliche Ahnung haben, ist ein Ausnahmefall. Und dann die tauschen natürlich die Argumente aus und es gibt auch noch,
Aktion, Reaktion, ja, die die
Ja. Insofern sozusagen mit kulminiert dann so ein bisschen in der Essenz dieses ganzen schriftlichen Verfahrens da mündlich. Es war schon spannend. Und diese halten ja auch nicht zurück. Also die Kritik gab's ja schon deutliche Märkte, die da die aus den Fragen kamen.
Kann man davon ausgehen, dass äh also weiß man, welche anderen Verfahren bei denen bei dieser Kammer jetzt noch anhängig sind oder kann man davon ausgehen, dass die jetzt Vollzeit an dem Ding arbeiten?
Nee, nee, die haben eine Menge parallel Verfahren und die haben auch nicht nur die große Kammer äh und die hatten auch so Informationsblätter über parallele oder ähnliche Verfahren oder so.
Morgen.
Ne, das ist nee, die sind, also die sind äh finde ich sehr hilfreich, ihre eigene Arbeit zu verstehen, die haben auch eine gute Webseite und so
Also, dass man, dass man die Prozedere da irgendwie versteht und so.
Was denkst du denn, also oder mal anders,
man weiß ja nicht, was rauskommt, aber was könnte denn so das maximale äh sein, was so auf so positiv rauskommt und was hältst du so für maximal
negativ so, weil also mit welchem Range siehst du quasi so den die Möglichkeit, wie das alles ausgeht und was das für Konsequenzen haben könnte.
Na ja, so das Optimum wäre natürlich, dass sie uns in weiten Teilen zustimmen. Das würde bedeuten, dass sie sagen, diese Form von Massenüberwachung,
rechtswidrig,
widerspricht der europäische Menschenrechtskonvention, dem grundlegenden Menschenrecht auf Achtung der Privatsphäre,
Es wäre eine Menge. Ähm aber da sind natürlich auch viele Details ähm zu sagen, wie wird es geprüft? Wie ist eigentlich sozusagen die äh die parlamentarische Kontrolle und die innerbritische Kontrolle? Wie entstehen so eine äh Berechtigung für äh
Überwachungsoperationen, also da könnte sich ja jeweils auch im Detail so äußern, wenn sie wollen. Ähm also ich glaube,
Mein Eindruck ist, oh, wenn ich so ein bisschen den EuGH-Urteil zur Vorzeitenspeicherung, wo ja ganz klar ist, dass die anlasslose Massenüberwachung so nicht geht, auch nach der EU-Kader,
Betrachte wird's eher an uns liegen, wie wir so ein Urteil auch mit politischem Druck,
äh vertreten. In in Deutschland zum Beispiel hat das Urteil vom Dezember zweitausendsechs einfach zu keiner Reaktion geführt, obwohl wir ganz klar ein Gesetz haben in Deutschland wart,
diesem Urteil widerspricht und auch der EuGH hat ja eine durchgreifende Wirkung gibt, ist dann sozusagen Geld mit Recht in Europa,
Wir müssen, glaube ich, dafür sorgen, dass wenn dazu kommt und ich denke, darauf wird's wohl hinauslaufen, dass diese Massenüberwachung als Menschenrechtswidrig, zumindest in Teilen gegeistert wird, dass wir daraus was umsetzen,
Weißt du? Und das geht doch glaube ich auch nochmal ein bisschen darum.
Also ein Umsetzen heißt ja also einerseits ja okay, das politische Einbringen, aber im Zweifelsfall halt dann auch nochmal jeweils national auf Umsetzungen zu äh klagen.
Aber das Gesetz kann natürlich also das konkrete Gesetz, der aber sozusagen ja letztlich schon wieder durch ein Neutgesetz ersetzt wurde, das kann natürlich dann als Menschenrechtswidrig wird dann noch so benannt.
Großbritannien ist aber auch immer schon wieder ein Schritt weiter, ne? Ich meine, es steht ja auch durchaus noch zur, äh, die Diskussion im Raum, dass sie sich auch diesen Zugriff des EGMR entziehen.
Ja, aber damit ist richtig. Na das würde aber bedeuten, dass sie aus der europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention sozusagen zurücktreten,
aber zumindest die Briten haben mir erzählt, es wohl eine sehr theoretische Diskussion, da hat wohl May auch kein es ist mehr so ein Drohding. Niemand wird es wirklich. Das haben mir zumindest die Briten die britischen Anwälte erzählt.
ich habe so ein bisschen anderen Eindruck, nachdem ich auch mit vielen dieser Anwälte du weißt ja die die Diskussion in Großbritannien ist sehr viel geringer,
und anders. Ja, ich glaube die Wirkung, die die Terroranschläge dort hatten, ist größer als bei uns. Aber.
Die Hammer hat auch nur sehr viel professionellere ähm Aktivistenszene. Das sieht man natürlich an diesen größeren Menschenrechtskanzleien sehr gut,
und die haben natürlich auch eine größere Öffentlichkeit. Das Englische wird da geht natürlich auch sofort in den amerikanischen Markt über, das wird internationaler berichtet,
fand ich schonende schon ein Unterschied zu ähm der deutschen Diskussion und die treten auch gegenüber den Geheimdiensten heute anders auf. Also diese diese tramponierte Image. Das wirklich schon deutlich aus,
Also glaub die Art wie der da aufgetreten ist wird nicht mehr als akzeptabel hier sehen ne? Ist es so diese ähm,
nur weil ihr Geheimdienste seid und sozusagen mit Terror winkt und paar anekdotische Beweise bringt,
trinkt ihr hier nicht durch. Das fand ich schon interessant. Und das sieht man auch an vielen anderen Stellen, an vielen anderen Stellen. Ich glaube, das könnte man für die Zitisdiskussion durchaus sagen. Also,
ähm,
Man sieht an vielen Stellen, dass eine Langzeitwirkung von Snowden gibt, dass man nicht mehr unbedingt anerkennt, dass irgendwelche geheimen Regeln akzeptabel sind, dass man auch hier,
Transparenz verlangt und es ist ja Teil davon. Ein äh es wird aber sicherlich auch noch andere Fälle geben zum Beispiel geheimdienstliche Hacking wird nach Straßburg ja auch noch kommen. Das ist ein anderer Fall. Ähm da kommt noch mehr,
erhoffe mir schon, was sehr grundsätzlich jetzt, weil wenn sie ein Prioritätverfahren haben mit einer Anhörung, dann auch weg mir schon, auch ein Urteil, wo sie sehr deutlich werden,
und du geht eben nicht geht, unmittelbar in ganz Europa. Dort hätte ich das finde ich schon geil.
Immer feste drauf.
Na was net, geht sogar bis Russland und Türkei.
Ja, nee, ich weiß ja, ich habe ja da meinen persönlichen Beef da mit den Briten irgendwie.
Na ja tatsächlich, also die Diskosuna ist gar nicht so tot, wie von hier immer so wahrnehme. Klar, die haben eine andere Medienlandschaft, aber die haben auch ein paar ziemlich gewiefte ähm Aktivisten,
mit einem langen, also wirklich langem Atem.
Ja gut, vielleicht in dem Bereich, so wie es wäre mal ganz gut, wenn sie nochmal so pro Europa äh äh Aktivisten auch nochmal irgendwo aus dem Hut zaubern und.
Äh die Brexit-Witze, die die drauf haben, kannst du dir vorstellen, wir waren natürlich danach auch noch reden und dann haben wir mal was essen, danach und mal quatschen und äh die sind natürlich alle keine Brexit-Freunde.
Wer jetzt die Aktivisten ja logisch.
Ne, die so eine Leute ja, na klar. Also das war schon die, die haben ungefähr so, wie wir BER-Witze haben oder so, haben die Brexit Witze äh.
Bringst du das neue BR.
Viele da noch Hoffnung,
dass man da vielleicht äh zu sagen in der Nacht, Theresa May Zeit oder mal anders abbiegen kann. Die Hoffnung ist nicht tot. Fand ich interessant. Aber gut, ich habe, ich habe halt selten so unmittelbar mit Briten zu tun. Die weiß.
Herr war ja regelmäßig einsitzen.
Also es war jetzt war ja mir, mich hat es extrem motiviert. Äh glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwie ähm,
wir haben halt das Glück in Europa ziemlich gute Gesetze zu haben in Bezug auf die Menschenrechtskonvention, die EU-Karte. Natürlich auch Grundgesetz und Defimissen uns dafür nur stärker einsetzen. Und dass man das kann, finde ich eine unglaubliche Privilegik.
bin ähm sehr motiviert nach Hause gefahren. Und da weißt du, wer ist also wir müssen das vielleicht offenlegen. Wir haben uns sozusagen später im Zug getroffen.
Wir haben uns durch Zufall im Zug getroffen. Das war übrigens auch sehr amüsant, wie wir uns dazu.
Ja, das musst du eigentlich mal erzählen.
Also ich habe so eine Angewohnheit in in Computernetzwerken zu gucken.
Wirklich. Oh, ich ahne es schon.
Nifferlin.
Nee, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich wusste nicht sniffen. Ich habe einfach nur einen Portscan gemacht.
Ja ja.
Tauchte da ein Host name auf, wo ich dachte hör mal.
Den du jetzt aber nicht nennen wirst, ist mein geheimer Nick.
Konstanz der SMS geschrieben hat, gesagt hat, sitzt du gerade in ICE lang Richtung Berlin Ostbahnhof.
Es war kurz hinter Karlsruhe, also ich war äh kurze, gerade über die Grenze und war gerade eingestiegen.
Und Constanze sagte so, ja, ich so, ne, dann sag doch mal bitte in welchem Wagen.
Lustige, weil Linus war gerade nicht im Chat, sonst hätte er mich wahrscheinlich direkt im Chat angelabert, aber ihr kriegt den eine SMS, also über einen ganz anderen Weg, sagt er, hey.
Ich hab erstmal mich in dem Netz umgeguckt, ob ich das chatten möchte oder so.
Kannst du das dann anpinken? Die Maschine hast du's probiert.
Na ja das steht standen halt die Hosnames und so, das.
Nee, ist schon klar.
Ja, ich merke ja nicht, wenn jemand an einem Port, äh das würde ich ja nicht merken an meinem Rechner.
Ich frage mich nur, ob die intern im Zug vielleicht noch ein Rauting haben, dass man irgendwie daran sehen könnte, in welchem Wagen noch einer sitzt.
Ach so, ja, das hätte man noch machen können, aber da, also vielleicht hätte ich da gucken können äh.
Die zwei zwei Wagen solltest du abschätzen können zwischen zwei Wagen.
Vielleicht über Timing oder so, ich weiß nicht genau wie, also ich habe nur ich war eigentlich nur so, hä? Mal gucken, wie viele hier schon wieder im Netz sind. Oh, Constanze.
Tatsächlich, also wir haben dann ein bisschen länger, aber meine Eindrücke ändern sich natürlich. Also ich habe da ein bisschen zusammengefasst. Da kam ich aber auch wirklich gerade zurück. Äh wenn man dann nochmal zwei, drei Tage, ich habe ja noch drüber geschrieben und dann äh entwickelt man, also da unterscheidet man ja nochmal, was wirklich wichtig ist und worüber man sich vielleicht nur im Moment geärgert hat oder was man
erstaunlich fand, das ändert sich ja immer so nach ein paar Tagen. Na ja, also ich bin da durchaus mit einem Schub äh aktivismus, Motivation zurückgekommen.
Wie schön, dass das auch mal wieder.
Ja.
So, dann äh nehmen wir uns nochmal. Also erstens hoffen wir dann äh auf äh durchschlagenden Erfolg des Europäischen Gerichtshofs für.
Sind wir hier wahrscheinlich einig.
Noch kurz um die Brexit Nummer der Comedy Briten und nicht mit ihrem Brexit raus, ne?
Na tatsächlich äh was den Datenaustausch angeht ist jetzt bereits angekündigt äh von der von der Theresa May Regierung, dass sie äh den den Daten geheimnislichen Daten ausstraf
Tauschring und auch unter den Polizei beibehalten wollten, unabhängig vom Brexit. Da wird's also ein anderer, haben sie schon angekündigt.
Aber die würden jetzt während Brexit Brexit bedeutet nicht EGMR ist nicht mehr zuständig.
Nein, nein, das ist ein völkerrechtlicher Vertrag, der besteht seit äh das dreiundfünfzig in Kraft getreten. Also da müssen sie dann schon extra sagen, wir wollen.
Union ist jetzt auch nicht so viel Junger, ne?
Ja, man sollte sich aber auch keine Illusion über die, die aktuell vorherrschende Idiotie machen, da in Großbritannien, das ist alles schon extrem realitätsfremd.
Das stimmt schon, aber tatsächlich sozusagen diese Compliance zu den Urteilen ist bei den Briten besonders hoch. Erstaunlicherweise, ich hätte das auch nicht gedacht, also die haben.
Das gilt auch übrigens für EU-Regeln, ne? Also der sich immer gegen etwas gewehrt haben, wenn's mal da ist, halten sie sich dann eher noch besser dran. Das ist richtig. Trotz alledem derzeit ist da einfach Unitown.
Äh wie gesagt, möglicherweise liegt's an dem Set, weil die britischen Menschenrechtsanwälte glaube ich auch auch versuchen, positive Dinge zu sehen. Die haben, die haben sozusagen Teil ihres Optimismuses schon noch gehabt. Also die denken über die Zeit nach Theresa Main nach.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nur dieser britische Sarkasmus auch noch mit dem krassesten klarzukommen und da irgen.
Ja, die können natürlich auch keine Brexitwitze mehr hören und sind ja.
Ja. Kommen wir zu den anderen äh Witzen, die man eigentlich auch schon nicht mehr hören möchte,
Ja, das Trumpthema äh der Woche irgendwie, was uns betrifft zumindest.
Das betrifft jetzt wirklich vor uns, ne? Also wir haben Constanze, was so eigentlich, was ich immer mal fragen wollte, beim sechsundzwanzig C drei, ne? Da warst du doch wahrscheinlich im Content Team,
Und das war glaube ich der äh oder war das fünfundzwanzig C drei al.
Noch nicht was du fragen willst, von daher weiß ich.
Julian Assange und Daniel Schmidt damals noch und der Pseudony äh Wiki Leaks vorgestellt haben.
Berg, der hat auch Schmidt-Berg und dann.
Da hieß er dann nicht mit. In dem Vortrag hieß der Daniel Schmidt und das war dann dauerte nicht so lange, bis dann oder ein Jahr später war dann. Ja, warum liegst du auch noch nicht wirklich bekannt in dem Sinne? Da haben sie sich vorgestellt,
Vortrag diesen BKA-Fall gehabt ähm.
Julius Bär war da.
Und äh die Bankhaus-Julius Bär. Das waren so die beiden Sachen, haben sie gesagt, so, ich glaube, wir haben hier eine ganz coole.
Fünfundzwanzig C drei, Alter.
Fünfundzwanzig C drei. Hierbei Dragons war auf jeden Fall das Motto der Veranstaltung.
Okay. Sagt er, ich hätte das nicht mehr so genau gewusst, also die Jahre äh müssen sie, ja, ja, ja.
Ähm jetzt,
ich sage das deswegen, weil das das war natürlich, das waren echt noch ganz andere Zeiten. Da waren die,
die großen, krassen Wiki Leaks Sachen waren alle noch nicht da. Dieser Vortrag ist wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht mal besonders oft gesehen worden. Der hatte, also weiß ich jetzt noch nicht mal, müsste man jetzt mal Playcount.
Na, ich war gerade sozusagen Beginn der Welle eigentlich äh aber sehr beginnen. Als.
Sehr, sehr beginnen. Äh hieß das neulich noch unter Sunshine Press und was.
Ja, aber die Guantanamo äh Akten waren schon raus, wenn ich mich recht daran nahe. Die sind nur in Deutschland nicht so sehr berichtet worden. Also die hatten schon.
Falls ja, da war schon.
Und sie hatten auch schon von den afrikanischen Leaks einige. Aber die hatten halt auch in Deutschland nicht viel.
Stimmt. Die Sachen, die dann irgendwann Wiki Leaks zur, also damals war Wiki Leaks noch nicht etwas, was man einen globalen Player nennen würde oder so.
Kein Haushalt erhol.
Irgendwelche Typen mit einer Internetseite hatten Julius Beer, Bankhaus Julius Behrmann angepisst,
und dem BKA hatten sie auch irgendwie eine Veröffentlichung die das PKA dann ähm durch so eine Takedown Notes quasi verifiziert hat. So, das war irgendwie so die Geschichte und aha okay, das könnte hier, das könnte hier etwas Größeres werden, wurde es ja dann auch ähm
Wir haben ohne da jetzt Ansporn auf Vollständigkeit zu erheben. Wir hatten irgendwie äh hier diese Cables,
Collateral Mörder, dass der die Leaks für die am Ende äh Chelsea Mening viele Jahre im Knast war, nochmal begnadigt wurde. Also,
von ähm Obama, Barack, Obama war ja mal Präsident der USA. Ähm und dann kam dann so war äh,
Was war noch in die große Wiki-League Num.
Sie hatten schon einen Afrika-Schwerpunkt, der hier nicht so sehr, sie haben sich sehr um Korruption in Afrika gekümmert. In vielen, in vielen Beispielen, aber ich glaube, am bekanntesten wurden sie dann ja noch wegen der äh Podesta mir jetzt, also als dann in den Wahlkampf ging, ich glaube, das ist eine wichtige, ja.
Das ist da, Wurz dann richtig.
Nur noch die FKN Warlocks. Darf ich erinnern an die also neben dem Depassion hatten sie dann auch noch die Nine Leven ähm,
genau, also da waren schon ein paar größere Dinge dabei und dann zuletzt sicherlich äh wollte äh die Walls sozusagen WhatsApp.
Ja genau, A natürlich die äh Hackinginstrumente der CIA. In den letzten, in letzter Zeit, also zwischendurch kam dann irgendwann nochmal das war zweitausendzehn oder zweitausendelf die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe gegen Julian Assange, die zu.
Ich glaube der VF ist eigentlich Nötigung, oder? Sexuelle Nötigung ist der Vorwurf. Also ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ja also die, die dann irgendwie
dazu geführt haben, dass er zunächst mit einer Fußfessel in Großbritannien rumrannte, dann flüchtete in die Equadoreanische Botschaft. Weil er befürchtete, dass die Briten hinausliefern würden und seitdem verharrt er jetzt auch schon wieder seit wie vielen Jahren sitzt er in diesem in dieser.
Würde sagen vier oder so oder fünf, sech.
Die Lokbuchnetzpolitikfolge dazu hat den großen Titel einmal Asyl und eine Flexbitte.
Ich glaube so also mehr als vier, oder? Äh ich glaube er war, als es mit losging, Juni zweitausenddreizehn mit einem Snown, war er schon in der Botschaft, also mindestens fünf. Ich würde sagen, eher sech.
Der hat irgendwie zwanzig zwölf, also fünf Jahre jetzt, ne?
War gar nicht so schlecht, oder? Ja, okay.
Also krasse Geschichte Wiki Leaks auch, ja? Äh dann,
Jetzt spätestens seit letzt seit einem Jahr dann wirklich im Gerede schon früher bei in der Szene immer wieder Kritik ausgesetzt, klar, ähm aber jetzt mit der Veröffentlichung
Podesta und Clinton Geschichten der der DNC Leaks und der Podesta-Mails ins insbesondere,
natürlich ein ähm entscheidender Einflussfaktor,
Auf die US-Wahl. Es wird ihm, es wird äh Julian Assange,
wurde natürlich mit dem Vorwurf konfrontiert, dadurch Donald Trump zur Präsidentschaft verholfen zu haben. Ähm es gibt eine sehr spannenden Podcast, wo Julian Assange dazu Stellung nimmt,
in der Diskussion mit Jeremy Scale ähm und da dann eben sagt so na ja, also entschuldigt mal bitte, wir sind eine
Publishing Plattform und wenn wir halt nur Leaks über Halloween Clinton kriegen, dann können wir halt auch nur die veröffentlichen und wenn wir nichts über Trump kriegen, können wir eben da nichts veröffentlichen und wir
arbeiten unsere Knie, wir arbeiten unsere Q
streng nach Eingang ab oder so was, ne? Wo da wo dann irgendwann auch Jeremy Skay sagt so Kammer und Julian.
Bin nicht glaubwürdig, ja.
Das war sehr, sehr wenig glaubwürdig. Und was jetzt also rauskommt, ist, dass äh,
Julian Assange, Twitter DMs an Donald Trump Junior geschrieben hat. Jetzt muss man wissen, Donald Trump hat zwei Söhne,
Die öffentlich bekannt sind, der eine,
Der eine ist der, der, also der, der, der eine ist, glaube ich, der, der gemeinhin als der Doofe gilt, ne, das ist der Erik, dem hat Julian Es.
Zumindest der Ungeliebte, ja.
Also der andere ist ja jetzt nicht weniger.
Also sie sind beide äh super reiche Großwildjäger und heißen Eric und Donald und Eric sieht auch sehr weniger sympathisch aus, was ihm glaube ich auch so ein bisschen das Gespört immer hinbringt.
Ja, der äh er guckt halt noch dümmer auf den auf den meisten Bildern als der.
Er neigt doch ein bisschen zu der trumpfen Frisur, was äh ja, na ja.
So, jetzt haben wir unser tolles Wiki Lease, die die Speerspitze der Transparenz äh ja, irgendwie Wissel, Blowing, groß geschrieben, paar Banken, paar amerika afrikanische Diktatoren, äh ein paar
US Regierungsgeschichten dick rausgeblasen,
Und jetzt schreibt dieser Donald Trump also dem äh dem Donald Trump Junior.
Wenn du meinst, assang, schreibt ihm, ja.
Äh der äh genau, Assange schreibt ihm und sagt äh schreibt dann so Nachrichten wie er ähm,
Hey, übrigens, wir haben gerade den vierten Teil der Podesta E-Mails veröffentlicht oder hey Don. Wir haben eine ungewöhnliche Idee,
Liko uns doch eine äh eine.
Eine.
Textreturen also eine Steuererklärung Steuerbescheid von deinem Vater die Vorteile sind. Erstens der größte der meiste Teil des Schadens wurde eh schon angerichtet, das heißt es käme nicht viel neue dazu. Zweitens,
Es könnte sein, dass die äh jeder in jedem Moment von einer mehr ähm gebeißten Quelle veröffentlicht werden.
Weniger objektiv.
Einer weniger objektiven Quelle, zum Beispiel New York Times oder ähm MSN BC veröffentlicht werden, die sie in dem schlimmsten Licht erscheinen lassen werden,
wenn wir sie veröffentlichen wird das dramatisch unsere die Wahrnehmung unserer unparteiisch,
Unparteilichkeit stärken. Das wäre der wirkliche
Das heißt, dass äh der der größere Teil, den wir jetzt gerade über Clinton äh veröffentlichen, noch mehr Impact hätte, weil wir ähm nicht mehr in dieser Pro Trump oder Pro-Russland-Ecke
stehen würden. Hier du kannst uns E-Mail und so weiter.
Sollten gleich mal sagen, woher wir das wissen, also wir also es gibt ja sozusagen nur zweistufige Veröffentlichung dieser dieser Nachrichten, wann DMs, also also keine Twitter-Nachricht, sondern eine.
Schreib.
Das ist wirklich echt unglaublich, unglaublich.
So und aber es geht noch ich habe die jetzt gerade nicht glaube ich nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge. Äh dann sagt er auch,
übrigens Donald echt gut zu sehen, dass dein Vater gerade über unsere Veröffentlichung spricht. Ich würde stark
empfehlen, wenn er twittert, dass er den Link WL Serge Punkt TK Twittert, da können die Leute nämlich dann könnt ihr eure Leute,
eure Follower dazu bringen den Inhalt zu durchsuchen, da sind bestimmt 'ne Menge großartige Stories drin die die Presse grade noch vergisst oder oder ignoriert.
Und darunter würde doch dem Botschafter posten. Ah ja genau.
Ah ja genau. Äh äh ich würde gerne äh äh hier äh ihr könntet mich als Botschafter ähm.
Denn der, der sag mal, wofür für Australien.
Für Australien. Ja. Na ja, er ist ja Australier.
In den USA. Er will ein Botschafter, ja, es ist also denke da. Es ist.
Das hätte mich jetzt nicht gewundert, also dass dass wir nicht von allem noch, dass am wenigsten, also das, das halte ich noch am für. Aber Alte, wie, wie, wie tief bist du gesunken, wenn du bei Donald Trumps Sohn,
um links bettelst auf deine,
Plattform und den den Argument, den irgendwie argumentierst mit ähm hey, ähm wir könnten, wenn wir könnten äh unparteilicher erscheinen, da hätten wir beide was von.
Es ist so wie wie die anderen Mails, die man immer so bekommt mit für Halle. Wir möchten gerne eine Link-Partnerschaft mit ihnen eingehen.
Ich habe einen Artikel über E-Books geschrieben,
wenn ich den bei ihnen in ihrem Podcast meinen Artikel veröffentlichen darf, dann äh dann linke ich von der Seite E-Books einfach selber machen Punkt DE Punkt VU Punkt TK.
Wir sollten äh trotzdem Constanze schon richtig äh begangen gerade. Wir sollten nochmal sagen, woher das jetzt eigentlich kommt, weil äh war das eine im Rahmen der Senatsuntersuchung oder.
Nee, nee, nee, erst wartet ein langer Artikel auf Atlantik und dann hat der Don Junior selber, wie genau wie er damals mit dem Russentreffen im Trump Tower gemacht hatte, zu sagen, selbst rausgehauen.
Genau, was wollt ihr denn? Also hier ist doch alles. Was immer nicht, was der denkt sich, was denkt der sich eigentlich.
Das klappt, das denkt er sich, der denkt sich damit, wenn ich das selber raushaue, ist äh kommt bei Fox News, äh wird bei Fox News gesendet, er hat alles veröffentlicht, hier gibt es nix zu sehen, toll.
Muss man wohl unterscheiden zwischen diesem Russenmeeting, als er die E-Mails raushaute, über die Frage, diese dieses Treffens ähm,
und sie wird Wiki Leaks Ding. Also hier geht's ja auch um ganz klassische rechtliche Sachen. Ich meine der wird ja, der ist ja
vermutlich äh in diesem, in diesem Moller Investigation darüber, ob er wirklich eine Form von Kolution gab, da ist er ja Teil. Also hier geht's ja auch darum, ob du dich
selber für was beschuldigst und so weiter. Also ich denke, der hat auch einen ganz schlechten, rechtlichen Rat.
Offensichtlich, aber äh übrigens, ja, ich weiß nicht, hast du eben gerade gesagt, Wiki Leaks hat geschrieben oder hast du gesagt, Assange hat geschrieben. Weil der, weil der Account ist ja der Wiki Leaks Account.
Dass den kontrolliert nach allem, was ich bisher gehört habe.
Idee, ich will das, ja, klar.
Julian, Himself und das deckt sich auch mit seinen Schlaf und Wachzeiten in dieser Embassy, also das.
Auch sonst niemanden, der bei Wiki Leaks in irgendeiner Form diese öffen.
Das möchte.
Nee, das Gerücht geht, das Pemalay Endersen äh Passwort auch hat.
Permela Hinders.
Kennst du dich, die Story.
Baywatch-Torte.
Na das geht doch immer, die geht auch immer in die Botschaft. Also sag mal, liest du kein Bulle.
Alter Tim, was ist das denn?
Nee. Ja, ich habe da mal äh dass da irgendwelche Promis rumlaufen, aber das.
Kuchen gebracht. Und und die hat auf ihrer Seite Perma Anderson. Dort kommt mehrere Gedichte für ihn veröffentlicht.
Und wir haben alle geweint, abends, als wir die gelesen haben.
Ist sie das nicht.
Äh die Welt, die ist echt aus dem Fugen,
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ich's richtig mitbekommen habe zwischen diesem dieser ersten Notiz und ich dachte, es äh die er hätte diese DMs auch irgendwie ähm,
im Rahmen der Kongresse oder Senatsuntersuchung auch schon gestellt. Und dann kam Wiki Leaks und hat aber erstmal nochmal dementiert, dass das so diesen Umf.
Wohl, genau, da wollte die die Dementi ist wichtig hier.
Genau so, ne? Und dann kam irgendwie ausgeredet Donald Trump und hat alles das äh bestätigt und damit Vicky Leaks auch widersprochen. Also ich meine äh wenn auch sonst stehen die schon lange sich diskreditiert hätte in dieser ganzen Geschichte, es hat jetzt spätestens einfach mal komplett durch.
Schönes äh dass dann noch dazu
also diese DMs waren ja mit Heimstamp und wo er dann äh fordert er den Donald äh den Donald Trump Junior offen, sagt ey dein Vater sollte unbedingt darüber hier Bericht sollte darüber twittern und von der DM,
Bis Donald Trump twittert. Äh die Dis One hier guckt wieder nicht auf die E-Mails von Hidory Clinton vergehen sechzehn Minuten.
Also du hast einfach äh Journalisten haben sich dann daran gemacht, tatsächlich auch nebeneinander zu stellen. Dann kannst du heute haben die auch teilweise einfach ins hübsch optisch aufgearbeitet und se,
anders als immer nur die DMs zu nehmen, sondern du siehst die Reaktion, die öffentlichen, dann siehst sozusagen den Kanal dahinter. Ich finde Tan bin eh ein bisschen beeindruckt, wie die amerikanische Presse nach wie vor äh die sind noch nicht in Langweil von dem Typ, die sind noch im.
Die kämpfen um um ihr Überleben, also ich meine, das ist ja äh höhere Motivation haben sie glaube ich niemals gehabt.
Aber jetzt also jetzt sitzen wir hier mit diesem.
Na, man kann da was lernen, man lernt da was.
Was machen wir denn da jetzt daraus, ne? Also ich meine das Wiki Leaks Projekt war ja auch so in unserem Umfeld halt, deswegen haben wir ja auch damit hier äh angefangen, ne. Das war halt so aha, okay, da will sich mal jemand um Transparenz äh kümmern und mittlerweile
ist das,
vollkommen Wild und Rogue irgendwie, also vollkommen äh außerhalb jeder äh sinnhaften äh Debatte und und Kontrolle und,
mittlerweile,
muss man natürlich auch vermuten, dass das Wiki Leaks da Teil dieses ganzen Prozesses war, ja,
Wer auch immer da den ersten Move äh gemacht hat, aber das hat uns halt da einfach mal so diesen Neo-Faschismus in USA mit eingebrockt. Ist ungeil.
WikiLeaks,
generell ist irgendwie zu seinem eigenen Geheimdienst verkommen, ne? Also es ist jetzt irgendwie so Julian Assanges, Geheimdienst. Übrigens, man muss auch dazu sagen,
Seine Rechtfertigung dafür ist, dass er das, dass das Teil von Wiki Leaks ähm,
beeindruckend, effektiver Veröffentlichungsstrategie ist Leute,
Also er tut so, er hat das irgendwie so ein bisschen sehr verschwubelt dargestellt so als hä ja das habe ich getan, um Donald Trump zu spielen, weil es ging dabei
darum die Effektivität unserer Veröffentlichung und der Plattform zu stärken und irgendwelche seht ihr nicht, wie ich ihnen äh gespielt habe und nee, sehen wir nicht. Sehen wir tatsächlich.
Ne, ich also wenn du jetzt schon anfängst sozusagen mit dem fünfundzwanzig C drei und einfach die letzten sieben, acht Jahre.
Ich finde, das muss man mal in dem Kon.
Ja, na ja, was ist es eigentlich mal gewesen? Also die Idee war ja wirklich radikale Transparenz herzustellen und Wizzle Blowern eine Möglichkeit zu geben, ihr Gewissen zu erleichtern und im zu sagen im nächsten Schritt dafür eine Öffentlichkeit herzustellen, damit man auch die
Originaldokumente nachlesen kann, aber
auch immer darum, Journalisten zuzuarbeiten. Man wollte sozusagen ursprünglich ja mal sagen, wir haben hier eine Plattform, wir sind ununzensierbar und
ihr könnt mit dem Original arbeiten und das war ja auch ein Angebot an Journalisten und an eben die Wurzelblower. Es also dat ist natürlich über die Zeit,
gut sicherlich glaube die die Vorwürfe und dann die Ermittlungen führten natürlich der zusätzliche auch auf die Person kapriziert hat, es gab das Buch was geplatzt ist, was ja sozusagen eine Form von Manifestum sein sollte und der
los, zwei, der hat dann sehr intensiv über die Person geschrieben. In der Zeit, wo er diese Fußfettfessel hatte, wo man dann oben ein Bild hatte.
Der hm.
Das fand ich sehr spannend. Und äh die Berichterstattung über die Person ist natürlich total überlagert worden und,
überwerfen mit äh mit den professionellen Journalisten, die hier eigentlich mal an den Stories mitgewirkt haben. Et hätte kein Coledar Mörder gegeben, zu sagen, wenn man nicht auch mit mit,
wenn die Journalisten nicht auch äh gerne aufgegriffen hätten oder die oder insbesondere die US-Depassion, ja, ohne ohne die Partner,
die das aufarbeiten, teilweise in alberner Weise, also Teffel und Merkel, ne, wenn ihr euch erinnert, aber ohne die hätte es ja so nicht gegeben. Und ist halt, wenn man das von von heute.
Hat sich aber mit regelmäßig, mit eigentlich mit allen Pressepartnern am Ende über irgendeinen Scheiß verstritten. Dann gab's diese wunderschöne
sehr sehr peinliche Aktion wo ich weiß nicht mehr genau welcher Guardian-Autor das war ähm ein Buchkapitel,
In einem Buchkapitel als Titel das Passwort veröffentlichte für eine verschlüsselte Datei, die er bekommen hatte, in der sich die unverschlüsselten,
die geschwärzten Botschaftsdepassionen befanden. Da wurden ja ganz viele Na.
Also auch vom Namen genau. Na dann gab's den ganzen.
Ne im Moment und dann war irgendwie eine andere Situation, wo du Wiki liegst, Underattack war, also diese Militärrhetorik hat er ja eh schon seit vielen Jahren,
ähm wo sie dann sagten, ja Mir hat unseren Server, was dann viele, viele tausend Leute getan haben und die hatten eine zwanzig Gigabyte Datei gemirot, wo einfach nur dran standen, lalala Punkt IS und dann ist halt irgendwann einer auf die Idee gekommen, als dieses Buch veröffentlicht wurde und hat mal dieses Passwort eingegeben und dann waren da halt einfach mal diese gesamten Cables
ungeschwärzt drin, wo keine Namen rausgestrichen waren. Und äh dann hat
das war ja dann der der endgültige Bruch äh Wiki Leaks Guardian.
Auch mit Daniel Dummscheidt Berg und dann kam das Buch
Also von von Domscheidberg wird ja auch nochmal also eine sehr persönliche Form der der Aufarbeitung war, erinnert euch noch an die Katze und so, da waren ja also die bevor zu so einer zu so einem Boulevardding.
Und irgendwie dummerweise scheint mir der, also der Eindruck, den ich habe mit dieser Boulevarddisierung und mit dieser mega mega Sache,
damit.
Werfst Leaks? We of the Biggest Leagues,
Nur bei dieses Liking Lack we do.
Wusste nicht, dass Tim so einen guten Trump macht,
ihr habt's ja jetzt nicht gesehen, ihr hattet auch optisch.
Ich schaue einfach zu viel Steven Kuhlbär. Das färbt ab.
Die haben also ich die die Geschichte von Wiki Leaks hier ist natürlich sehr sehr komplex aber es ist einfach ein,
es bleibt einfach ein bedauerlich anzusehen, wie diese Organisation oder Person, ich glaube eine besonders große Organisation war es nie und es ist nie gewesen, weil der Typ halt niemanden,
davon überzeugt kriegt besonders lange mit ihm zu arbeiten. Ähm dass es dann also jetzt in diese Nummer ähm ein guter
Freund von uns äh hat mal sehr weise gesagt so inzwischen ist Wiki Leaks eigentlich sein eigener Geheimdienst geworden. Das, was ähm diese, was jetzt auch die USA natürlich schon so sagen. Also die die nennen das halt auch als die betrachten die als ein,
Intelligence Actor. Ja, der.
Müsste man natürlich fairerweise müsste man die andere Seite wahrscheinlich ansprechen. Natürlich ist klar, ähm dass,
der hat schon die Geheimdienste in den USA echt angepisst und das ist auch klar, dass die nicht fein sind damit
gegen ihre Feinde vorzugehen, auch jenseits des Rechtlichen, ja? Weil man muss schon sehen, dass das Image, was er heute trägt, sicherlich auch Teil teilweise durch durch Kampagnen gegen ihn persönlich geführt wird. Da hab,
Zweifel, die werden schon versucht haben zu ihnen auch persönlich zu diskreditieren. Der der Punkt ist nur an diesem an diesem Stück, was man lesen kann, was ich auch jedem empfehle zu lesen. Siehst du halt sehr viel auch über über diesen Charakter
Und das kannst du keiner Schmutzkampagne mehr oder so, wisst ihr. Da siehst du einfach, da ist ziemlich deutlich äh Denken
Auf beiden Seiten übrigens. Ich finde das auch Donald Trump, also vor allen Dingen um die Reaktion von Junior und Senior, dann siehst, da siehst du eine Menge. Es sind äh na ja, das sind natürlich auch keine Politiker, die sie jetzt gewählt haben, also.
Hintergrund muss man also zwei Sachen muss man dazu natürlich sagen, also Halloween Clinton wird,
übereinstimmt, damit zitiert, Country Just Ron the Sky, also es äh in Bezug auf Schule in Assange. Also der Julian Assange hatte viele Gründe jetzt persönlich nicht unbedingt zu wollen, dass äh Hillary Clinton
Ähm Präsidentin wird, aber da in diesem Fall muss ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen, da hätte ich jetzt mal,
Julian Essanges, persönliches, persönliche Präferenz und Beef mit Hillary Clinton jetzt mal so gegen das Allgemeininteresse zurückgestellt, weil,
also wer hätte,
Trump vielleicht auch gewonnen ohne diese Mail-Geschichte, ich weiß es nicht. Ähm ist ist immer sehr sehr schwer ähm zu sagen, aber.
Nee, der also wurde also so wurde jetzt auch nicht so spitzen wollen. Dafür ist ja auch viele viele noch nicht gut untersucht, wie eigentlich die Meinungsbildung stattgefunden.
Aber man spielt einfach nicht mit den Schmuddelkindern so. Man macht das nicht, du kannst nicht sagen, du bist Julia aus Horsch und hier der geile äh Transparenz und haste nicht gesehen, Wahrhaftigkeit in die Politik bringen und dann halt irgendwie die,
das geht halt nicht.
Na ja, insofern, also man ich meine, wenn man so ein bisschen was wissen will oder sich eine Meinung bilden will, sollte man Zeit lesen. Also, weil wenn man, wenn man Interesse hat an sozusagen der Entwicklung von dieser Plattform und die Mitfahrer ja mitverfolgt hat, aber wir wollen, glaube ich, echt nicht mehr Zeit auf
äh auf das Verschwenden. Ich meine, der Trump-Unfall ist ja sozusagen ungerugen, den können wir ja jeden Tag äh verfolgen.
Zeitlupe verfolgen.
Hoffe nur, dass er nicht daran endet, dass er tatsächlich äh eine nukleare Eskalation äh in die Wege geleitet. Ich kann das einfach nur hoffen. Also mit anderen bleibt uns ja nicht.
Bin auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr enttäuscht von den Verschwörungstheoretikern. So generell, weil bisher bin ich ja immer davon ausgegangen
Präsident kommt, der dann tatsächlich mal gegen die Geheimdienste äh arbeitet, dass dann äh auch entsprechende Reaktionen kommen, ne? Und das sozusagen der Deep State, das schon regeln wird. Und der Deep State macht einen Scheiß. Also,
offenbar gibt's das alles nicht.
Na ja, kommen äh so eine Geschichte der der Vereinigten Staaten haben seiten so viele Militärs, das weiße Haus zu sagen besetzt und schon bemerkenswert. Kelly, McMaster.
Ja gut Militärs.
Also die hätten das eigentlich militärisch geeigne.
Naja gut.
Chef ist im Militär. Also ich will nur sagen, also äh hatte ich schon jetzt überwendet, dass er jetzt genau ein Jahr rum, oder? Ja, ziemlich genau ein Jahr rum. Seit der Wahl,
Ähm, du siehst schon, dass sich was verändert hat und die, die da rausgeflogen sind und die, die jetzt neun drin sind, haben halt auch schon sehr enge Beziehungen zu dem.
Also wo man, glaube ich, den Deepstate sieht, ist, als irgendwie, weil wo ist der Donald Trump Themen Putin übern Weg gelaufen? Hat sich nachher vor die Presse gestellt und sagt,
Putin hat mir, nee, nee, das war hier in Asien. Äh in Vietnam oder was?
Ja, ja. Im Vietnam oder was? Asia treffen.
Putin hat mir gesagt, es gab keine Kolution. Ich glaube ihm. Okay, alles klar. Dann kommt nach Hause, äh die du äh Trump äh ist hier überhaup.
Wer würde dem Lupen reinen Demokraten nicht glauben, nicht.
Einen Tag später sagt er so ich glaube unseren Geheimdiensten hat irgendwie so ab und zu wird er dann doch glaube ich nochmal von irgendjemand zur Seite genommen. Aber hier zur Seite genommen Tim, ich wollte fragen, ob ich gleich noch ein bisschen hier äh hochladen kann zu Facebook,
weil.
Nur deine eigenen Bil.
Näher, weil ich möchte nämlich also damit damit kein Revent-Porn veröffentlicht wird auf Facebook, sondern den den jetzt lieber direkt schon mal schicken.
Weil's die ganzen Food von unserem Nackspunkt Podcast da rein hier.
Na ja, deswegen möchte euch diese Situation eigentlich mal schildern, damit ihr auch die Facebook-Logik versteht. Das ist so
Weg so abends äh mit dem äh Mann oder Frau deines Herzens weiß ich nicht, rauchst die Zigarette danach und guckst dir deinen Porn an zusammen, ist ja immer lustig und dann
Nein, kriegst du dir den Typ irgendwie an und denkst, na, der sieht aus in zwei drei Jahren, sieht der doch echt aus wie ein Wenchport und lädst das erstmal hoch. Ich finde net eine absolute, tolle Sicherheitsmaßnahme, ja
ne, weil wie, wie ist denn sonst zu verstehen? Habe ich das falsch verstanden.
Also die die haben ein Foto DNA.
Oh, wir haben das noch gar nicht erklärt. Huch!
Tool, was sie, sie haben ein Tool, was quasi über das Hashing von Bildern hinausgeht, ne? Also die klassischerweise, wenn man jetzt sagt, man will eine äh Datei äh verbieten, dann würde man jetzt also ein sehr naiver,
Ansatz wäre eine Prüfung über diese Datei zu machen, zu sagen eine Datei dieser Prüfsumme werden wir nicht mehr annehmen. Dann reicht es aber natürlich ein Bit in der Datei umzuwerfen und du.
Der Hash ändert sich.
Der Hash ändert sich und dieser Teil würde wieder durchgehen konfrontiert mit vielen Jahren und äh der der Takedown Noates und vor allem natürlich auch das ähm,
der der Sittenwacht über Facebook, ja, was da in Bildern hochgeladen wird, sind die ähm haben die äh Algorithmen.
Ich glaube, Brüste detektieren können die besonders gut.
Brüste können sie detektieren, sie können.
Nippel, Nippel, Nippel Detection.
Na, aber wir wollen schon ein bisschen größer kommen. Also wenn's jetzt um ähm also wirklich ein Nude-Fotos geht, dann musst.
Der Brüste ist vollkommen irrelevant.
Also jedenfalls, sie haben da, sie haben da Ahnung.
Sie haben Verfahren erstens die Inhalte von Bildern zu erkennen, zweitens ähm ein Bild, was auf das ist ein Copyright Claim gibt oder sonst was,
Auch wenn es modifiziert wurde, wiederzuerkennen und zu von vornherein zu verhindern.
Vor allen Dingen auch Bewegbilder.
Und das genau und das sogar jetzt auch auf Bewegbilder, ne? Also mit mit äh mit mit äh Standbildern ist das irgendwie halbwegs äh vorstellbar. Mit Bewegbildern wird das dann echt irgendwann crazy,
Aber sie können es. Und jetzt sagen sie, ah, hör mal, diese Technologie, die könnten wir ja auch nicht nur in den äh in den Dienst der Content-Mafia stellen, sondern ähm wir könnten sie ja auch sagen, pass mal auf, wenn du ähm,
selbstgemachte Pornografie hast, die du nicht,
Irgendwann mal bei Facebook sehen möchtest, dann schick sie uns lieber gleich, dann führen wir sie diesen,
Prozess zu, werden uns also werden sie, sie nennen's trotzdem noch Heschen, es geht natürlich irgendwie die Analyse geht weiter darüber hinaus. Und dann schreiben wir an unsere Datenbank, dass das deine Pornografie ist, die wir bei Facebook nicht veröffentlichen sollen.
Also weil wir beide wahrscheinlich äh der Phänomen Porn es denen noch nie begegnet, also weil die annehmen, der der also in Zukunft wird der Rovangeporn bei Facebook landen, wo man da ja kein Power hochladen kann.
Ich frage, ich weiß nicht, was das soll. Also ich mein.
Die Logik erschließt sich. Tim ist doch da erfahren bei Revanche Porn, ne?
Hast du schon mal?
Ob ich schon mal Reventsporn veröffentlicht habe oder ob ich schon mal erpresst wurde.
Ich, also nee, hast du schon mal, hast du schon mal ein Video bei Facebook hochgeladen, weil die sind hier sitzen jetzt drei Belinde und reden von der Farbe, ne.
Ich, Facebook, ich äh bin auf Facebook ein reiner Platzhalter, weißt du doch.
Nee, nee, das Ding ist ja, ich glaube, hier wir hauen zwei Sachen zusammen, wenn die Amis Revench Porn sagen, meinen die nicht unbedingt bewegten Porn, den wir uns jetzt vorstellen.
Ne, auch Fotos halt.
Äh die genau, also wo.
Also Revench Pon ist, du hast eine eine Partnerschaft, die geht in die Brüche, du hast da noch so einige digitale Relikte aus von schöneren Zeiten und ähm.
Der der Ex-Partner lädtet.
Möchtest, möchtest, die mit dir äh ja der einer von beiden lädt die halt.
So wie ich das verstanden habe ist so ihr ihr erklärtes Ziel ist wir wollen dir ein Werkzeug in die Hand geben ähm mit dem quasi bestimmte Fotos,
zuverlässig erkannt werden können und da es halt mit so einer Heschsumme nicht getan ist
Müssen sie da halt ihre AI drauf schmeißen und machen da sozusagen Bilderkennung, wie man das eben heutzutage macht, womit sie auch Features erkennen, et cetera und gewinnen damit natürlich ein viel flexibler
äh zu erkennen, denn Fingerabdruck dieses Fotos, ne? Nur dass halt anders als jetzt bei Apple äh,
diese ganze Logik einfach nur bei ihnen ist. Das heißt, das Foto muss auf ihren Server sein, damit sie das dort auch machen können.
Wenn du lädst nackt Fotos bei Facebook hoch. Hallo. Sorry. Hallo, ja ihr.
Sage ja nicht, dass es gut ist. Ich sage nur, das ist die Logik da.
Und weißt du warum? Damit sie da nicht hochgeladen werden.
Es lustig ist, es gab ja im im äh ich erwinde das jetzt mit Apple, weil ähm da ist ja diese ganze Logik quasi aufs Gerät äh ausgelagert, weil sie sich da jetzt halt äh auch drum kümmern. Lustigerweise gab's ja da auch eine App,
Bis vor Kurzem, die, jetzt habe ich den Namen leider vergessen von dem Ding. Äh die quasi,
Solche Fotos bei dir automatisch findet und dann zu verhindern, dass sie in irgendwelchen Alben und Sharings zu landen. Diese App jetzt wiederum ist aus dem App Store geflogen, aus Gründen, die sich mir weder erschließen, noch genau äh äh recherchiert habe,
Ist auf jeden Fall ein heißes Thema und äh es ist natürlich ein bisschen äh absurd, der der Weg, den Facebook da wählt.
Es ist absurd, dass wir in Treten muss. Ja, ja.
Vertreten muss. Es war ja der Test australisch. Also das ist ja auch so eine Wahrnehmungssache. Also das lässt niemand dit wie für Postillon hält, sondern das Glas, dass die das auch so mein.
Das für ein Scherz.
Aufforderung ist, das sagt er offen über uns, oder?
Ich habe ich habe, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe gesagt, Fake News. Ich habe das gelesen, Guardian, dachte so erster April ist nicht, haben die irgendwie Anfang November ist Set F.
Fake News, das ist Face News.
Face News und dann habe ich gedacht ist das irgendwie,
dann habe ich überlegt, ob das vielleicht was damit zu tun hat, dass irgendwie am fünften November, dass die vielleicht am Guifforx Day vielleicht irgendwie eine so eine Tradition haben, Scherze zu machen, dann war die Meldung aber vom sieb
Dann habe ich recherchiert, ob der siebte November irgendwie ein Witztag ist es nicht
oder ich hab's oder die haben's echt gut versteckt, dass es die meinen das ern.
Na ja also zweierlei, das ist ja auch die haben betont.
Wahrgenommen.
Ja wie problematisch das Problem ist. Also das ist ja der, also das ist ja nicht wurde ja auch ernsthaft darüber berichtet, war ja nicht so, dass jetzt die Kommentatorin sich da einen lustig gemacht hätten, sondern die haben A berichtet, dass das Problem groß ist und wie Facebook sozusagen als allein mögliche Macht
dagegen kämpfen würde. Das fand ich schon interessant, wie die, also ihr müsst auch mal sehen, was wir da für einen Abstand haben von den Facebook-Klickern.
Äh natürlich ich weiß nicht wie groß das Problem zahlenmäßig ist. Ich glaube natürlich, dass das eine, also das ist natürlich eine völlig völlig asoziale Sache, sowas zu machen, steht überhaupt nicht zur Frage.
Wert ist auf jeden Fall intimes, faire, das ist ja mehr als Privatsphäre, ich glaube, dass jeder einzelne Fall ist krass einfach.
Ja und soll also man sich jeder, der jede Person, der es in Erwägung zieht, sowas zu tun, sollte mal in der Bewegung zu nässi vielleicht irgendwann auch nochmal irgendeinen anderen Sexualpartner finden möchte, äh der bereit ist, äh sich mit der Person überhaupt.
Ist auch strafbewährt, also halt mal.
Ist auch einfach also der Zug aus gutem Grund und gerade weil Sachen schwer aus dem Internet wieder rausgehen ist ist sowas halt eine eine absolut.
Nee, nicht Sachen, Porn geht schwer aus dem Internet raus.
Ah, andere Sachen auch, aber Japoren noch schwieriger. Ähm.
Äh ähm also ihr kauftet ja immer, dass mich mal klatscht, Gott sei Dank mit allen Experten mir eine gute Beziehung.
Aber dieses jetzt die Idee so sicherheitshalber schon mal alles bei Facebook hochzuladen, die überzeugt mich jetzt auch nicht als Lösung des Problems, mus.
Ist ja zum Beispiel auch jemand filmt dich in einer Airbnb Wohnung, die du nicht bezahlt hast. Also ich meine, da ist ja mehr als nur äh zerbrochene Beziehungen.
Dann kann ich aber das Video nicht hochladen. Das habe ich ja dann nicht. Wenn der mich heimlich.
Ah ja du der tatsächlich stellt so ein bisschen was von Neuheit ausden.
Also was ich gerne hätte, wäre, das fände ich, das finde ich wirklich gut, wenn ich sagen könnte, hier ist ein Foto von mir, ich will nichts von mir auf eurem Ding da haben, alles weg, alles gelöscht, Foto-DNA, Linus nicht auf Facebook,
Das fände ich okay, das wäre ein Angebot, ja? Müsste man dann auch nicht nackt machen vielleicht.
Ist aber sobald man getect wird, verschwindet das Fotoautoma.
Die neuste Forschung gesehen hat, wie die sozusagen Bewegbilder faken und Köpfe auf andere, also weiß nicht, wird sich vielleicht der Übrigen in Zukunft.
Ja wahrscheinlich. Also das wird schon doch alles ganz schön schlimm werden, also ich denke mal so die technologischen Durchbrüche in dem Bereich in den nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahren die wird hier noch so einiges.
Meinst du, du veröffentlichst einfach Eventsporn ohne jemals irgendwas.
Trump wird einfach Hillery Clinton Porn irgendwie ins Netz schmeißen.
Hat er doch schon, hat er doch schon, hat er alles schon getan mit na ja mit CNN oder was? Da wir diese.
Ja, wir brauchen schon noch die, die Moskau feilt sind, aber ob die echt sind, wenn man schon genau prüfen müssen.
Wollen wir wirklich mal sehen. Das ist der einzige Reventsporner, den ich echt interessiert wä,
Golden Schauer.
Äh also gut, also sie können, ich glaube, das äh also an dem an dem Beispiel kann man eine Menge lernen, aber wir brauchen, glaube ich, darüber, also von uns wurde, glaube ich, niemand auf die Idee kommen, dann nackt Fotos zu einer Werbeplattform hochzuladen.
Wurde wahrscheinlich noch ein Häkchen machen muss für ich tritt alle Rechte an diesem Bild ab.
Äh tust du eh durch die Nutzungsbedingungen bereit.
Ich, also ich ich finde es spannend, dass dass wir so, dass die äh die haben es geschafft, sich das auszudenken,
durch ihren kompletten internen Prozess zu kriegen, eine Pressemitteilung zu machen, weil eine eine Pressekonferenz zu dem Thema,
dass ein Artikel im Guardian entsteht und nirgendwo unterwegs zwischendurch jemand eingeliefert werden musste, weil er irgendwie einen Zwerchfellkrampf hatte.
Also wir hatten also mit allen Leuten, die ich an dem Tag, wir haben alle gelacht, e.
Intristing Times. Intristing Times. Ich hab's nicht geglaubt.
Ja, ja, die sind dann auch schon ganz schön äh entrückt. Und ich meine äh Facebook, das war auch wieder beim Trump-Komplex, finde ich ohnehin schwierig, die Rolle, die sie da jetzt gerade äh quasi so Schritt für Schritt zu geben, diese.
Ach so, mit der Anhörung und dem und.
Einfach gerade mit mit äh ihrer Beteiligung äh an der äh Darstellung von Trump und Hillary Clinton äh in Wahlen, ne? So wie sie sich da haben, massenhaft äh,
Werbung haben kaufen lassen. Ich meine, sie haben einfach in dem Höchstmaße davon profitiert so und meine,
Wie auch immer sich Zuckerberg da äh präsentiert hat, ne? Dieser Peter äh wie heißt der nochmal Thiel,
Ja, der irgendwie einer der äh ersten Investoren und größten Profiteure von Facebook war, der sich ja aktiv dahinter Trump gestellt hat,
keine Ahnung wie der mittlerweile die Welt sieht, aber das ist halt auch alles so ein Komplex. Ich wäre nicht so überrascht, wenn wir dann noch mehr hören werden in der nächsten Zeit.
Ja äh wir lassen mal Facebook hinter uns für heute, oder? Obwohl, nee, wir bleiben bei Facebook oder bei.
Bleiben wir bei Facebook,
Ja, es gibt eine eine interessante Recherche bei Netzpolitik Org, die sich damit auseinandersetzt, er veröffentlicht von Markus Reuter, die sich damit auseinandersetzt, dass es mehrere,
türkische oder türkisch verwurzelte Menschen.
Vor allen Dingen türkisch kritische.
Türke, genau, türkisch, kritische Menschen auf Facebook gibt, die da unter unter anderem,
signifikante Reichweiten haben, aber Follower verlieren und zwar irgendwie in so Raten zwischen fünfzig und zweihundert am Tag. Das würde ich, könnte ich mir nicht lange leisten, aber ähm.
Ja, du hast zu wenig Nacktfotos auf deinem Profil.
Ja, muss ich mal mit Facebook reden, vielleicht muss ich da die die ein bisschen lockern. Ähm aber die ähm,
Ähm dann haben sie jetzt irgendwie mal hinterher recherchiert, wer denn da so erfolgt entfolgt hat und dann festgestellt, okay, das sind echte Menschen. Außerdem ähm,
hat Facebook dann bei einer dieser Person gesagt, okay, wir wollen mal alle Daten haben, damit wir mal schauen können, welche Follower wir da so haben, damit wir nachher sehen können, welche verloren wurden und irgendwie üblicherweise
kriegt man seine Facebookdaten da eben innerhalb weniger Stunden oder Minuten und.
Ne, die Umfrage, also wir hätten eine Umfrage gemacht, da waren's sogar nur vierzehn. Im Schnitt waren so vierzehn Minuten. Manche hatten dann nach einer Minute schon. Aber so der Schnitt war äh,
Na wir hätten so, ich glaube, da haben sich über hundert Leute beteiligt, die dann wir haben so gefragt, ey könnt ihr mal machen, könnt ihr mal klicken und mal messen, wie lange das dauert und der Schnitt war glücklich, so vierzehn Minuten.
Und jetzt ist irgendwie die Frage, was ist da los, ja? Also äh Facebook sagt, ja, nee, wir haben, wenn dann, wir, das sind alles,
aber mit einigen, einige sind eben real existierende Person oder mit so einigen davon real existierenden Personen wurde Kontakt aufgeordnet, die haben da niemals jemanden entfolgt und jetzt fragt man sich, was erlaube Facebook.
Ne, das Interessante ist auch zu spekulieren,
Warum das wohl geschehen ist? Also das ist ja also gibt ein Prinzip jetzt erstmal nur zwei Varianten, wenn wir sozusagen in seinem Wegkämpfung entweder es sind äh von Menschen
gemacht oder aber hier hat irgendeine Software nach irgendwelchen Parametern sozusagen automatisch, also die zwei Wege gibt's ja.
Würde schätzen, da war eine ich, also wahrscheinlich war eine Software falsch getunt.
Na, das ist ja natürlich interessant, wie sich Facebook dazustellt, also ob sie sowas einräumen, dass das überhaupt sein kann sozusagen. Also klar, bei den, wenn du bei einer Türkei ist, dass du ja sofort auch dieser Extremismusfragen, Terrorismusfragen
weil der verbotene Organisationen gibt und so weiter äh wo du dir vorstellen kannst, dass der Zusammenhang,
zu einer automatisierten Form von Veränderung, ja. Und da wird's ja interessant auf's
ob's so ist. Natürlich äh also Markus Reutler war ja relativ aktiv. Er wird ja wahrscheinlich heute oder wenn der Podcast raus ist, wird er das wahrscheinlich schon geschrieben haben, in der,
durchaus Kontakte, mit mit man will ja auch mal von dem Konzern eine Antwort darauf. Das ist ja eigentlich was zu vergangen ist. Also ich finde die Transpar.
Twitter-DM schreiben.
Ja. Also äh interessant ist natürlich, also er hattet auch übersetzen lassen auf Englisch
ist einfach ein interessanter Fall, äh der glaube ich aber typisch für viele ist. Ich glaube, der erste, der so richtig debattiert wurde, war ja noch irgendwie dieser World Socialist-Zeit. Da ging's aber eher um die Nachrichtenverbreitung, plötzlich die haben plötzlich einfach viel, viel weniger Treffe gekriegt und haben sich gefragt, ey wieso
als so richtig viel.
Weil sie nicht bezahlt haben. Oder.
Sind ja immer so die Fälle, die erst so ein die als erstes so ein Phänomen aufdecken und vor allen Dingen Alternativen Medien sind und keine keine großen Liste. Da wird's ja immer interessant, die dann soweit aufdecken und den Konzern zu einer Stellungnahme nötigen oder zum Erklären,
Und ich glaube eventuell ist das äh also wenn wir sehen, ob die noch was dazu sagen,
Na und? Ja, also Schamberger ist ja auch einfach sehr aktiv. Die arbeitet ja auch öffentlich damit. Mal sehen, ich bin gespannt.
Die Seite von Lokbuch Netzpolitik hat auch in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so viele neue Follower bekommen.
Seit der türkei kritisch etwa.
Seite auf Facebook. Scheiß doch auf die Facebook-Seite.
Seite, weil äh nein, ich will auch bei Facebook äh erfolgreich sein, Tim.
Oh Gott, jetzt habe ich eh das aber jetzt so ein Wespennest, oder? Oh Gott, oh Go.
Nee, Junge.
Dann müsst ihr Nacktfotos hochladen, Män.
Weißt du, diese.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass das jemand sehen möchte.
Ich würde es gibt Menschen, die diesen, diese Facebook-Seite nutzen. Da die Facebook-Seite,
äh hat über so einen, so einen Automatismus ähm veröffentlicht, die diese die Artikel, die ich äh im im für Lokwood Netzwerk sammel. Also ich sammle ja quasi Artikel.
Ja, aber auch die Podcasts selbst, oder? Die doch auch.
Ich glaube, dass es inzwischen kaputt, die werden dann, äh dass es irgendwie das geht nicht mehr und das ist alles irgendwie schmerzhaft. Dieses Facebook ist einfach nur schmerzhaft. Ich gucke mir das an und ich komme mir wirklich vor. Also ich komme mit diesem nicht zurecht.
Keiner kommt das.
Niemand, ich weiß auch nicht, was da passiert. Eigentlich ist immer, wenn ich da eine Handlung voll führe in diesem Facebook, dann steht irgendwie,
wenn ich dann denke, ist jetzt vielleicht fertig, dann steht da, hat keiner gesehen, drücke auf Boost und bezahle neun Dollar, damit das damit wir das jemanden an,
Nein, nicht verrückt.
Frag ja nur.
Ja, ein nein, man muss, wenn man Geld gibt, muss man sich äh muss man sich genau überlegen, weil wenn wem du Geld gibst, der hat das ja dann und macht damit was.
Ich wollte damit nicht sagen, dass du das sollst. Ich wollte ja nur mal wissen.
Kaufen mit einem. Wenn dann kaufe ich bei, bei Ivan Follower, aber noch nicht bei Facebook live. Nee, aber keine Ahnung.
Aber das machst du doch auch immer bei Twitter, dein, dein oder nicht.
Die, die ja bei Twitter werden die automatisch gepostet, das funktioniert, da funktioniert das Skript, aber dass der diese Automatisierung bei Facebook halt irgendwie nicht mehr funktion.
Offenbar Tim daran wenig Interesse.
Wenn unter unseren, also na ja und dieses diese diese App ist auch es ist alles ganz schmerzhaft, vielleicht wenn wenn jemand das,
weiß, wie man sowas macht.
Äh du musst dich mehr damit beschäftigen, viel viel mehr stundenlang mehr pro Tag.
Na diese, diese App hier, die iOS-App für die Seite, die macht jedes Mal, wenn sie's, wenn jemand Like drückt, äh ähm gibt die mir eine Push-Notification.
Ähm gibt ihm mir eine Pushnote.
Und dann ist da irgendwie, was weiß ich, Gerhold, hast nicht gesehen, hat deine Seite gelikt und dann musste irgendwie durch fünfundachtzig Likes scrollen, bist dann irgendwie so farblich nicht unterscheidbar, jemand einen Kommentar dazu geschrieben hat, den ich ja vielleicht, der mich ja interessieren würde, ja,
Also das ist einfach leider.
Ist eine, ist eine reine Kommunikationskatastrophe und geht einfach gar nicht und es ist al.
Ja aber es gibt einige Leute, die viel zu recht. Die haben sich dann auch zum.
Ich finde das so geil, wenn die Leute sich die durch ihre Hand, äh weißt du, mit diesen mit diesen Wackeluhren, dass sie dass sie sozusagen immer so einen so einen so einen kleinen Stromschlag am Handgelenk kriegen, wenn du irgendeiner ein Like drückst, dann liegt's so herzlich. Das könnte ich mich bei Armin drüber. Weil schon diese Notifizierung einer Uhr,
Worte Mandinos, ha.
Ja, ich habe immer viel. Hier hat einer.
Stromschlag, nennst du das? Ist doch kein Stromsch.
Nee, aber du merkst, du merkst so physisch? Nee, ich habe das jetzt, das habe ich übertrieben, aber du merkst so der Physisch. Vier Leute stellen sich dazu ein. Ich, ne, das ist so eine lustige Konditionierung nicht,
Linus ist natürlich nicht so der ist immun.
Mit diesen Leuten, das ist echt äh vorsichtig sein. Ich.
Mach mal deine Arme frei da bitte. Ich komme, ich komme das äh ich koppel. Nein, oh, ich wusste.
Ich koppel das äh ich koppel das mal eher aufs Spendenkonto irgendwie. Kling kling.
Aber ihr habt beide keine Geräusche, oder? Also ihr würdet euch nicht nein. Oh, ich sehe, oh Gott, jetzt habe ich na.
Aber ich habe letztens war ich bei einer Veranstaltung, da war ähm da war Sandra Maischberger
Und ich habe dann eine Nortification gekriegt und dann kam noch einem noch eine. Ich sage, was ist los? Guck auf die Uhr und die hat mich dann sofort darauf angesprochen, sowas, warum gucken sie auf ihre Uhr
gefällt's ihnen hier nicht oder so? Weil ich irgendwie boah, das war nächste Woche muss ich diese Notifications äh abschalten, ja. Also diese Notifications an der Uhr sind ablenkend.
Ich weiß nicht, da muss jeder seinen Weg fin.
Kam aber nicht von Facebook.
Wüsstet ihr nicht.
Die hier kommen Lotifications äh gerade lassen wir das.
Leute, wir müssen jetzt mal hier, wir haben jetzt schon zwei Stunden zusammen gequatscht und wir sind immer noch nicht am Ende.
So, ganz Kurzmeldung jetzt, digitale Gesellschaft sucht eine neue Geschäftsführung.
Wenn ihr endlich mal was sinnstiftet im Leben machen wollt, dann solltet ihr also unfähig seid, euch da unbedingt mal bewerben. Das läuft doch bis wann, vierter Umgang bis wann das läuf.
Ähm einschließlich neunzehnter elfter.
Also zacki jetzt.
Wäre jetzt noch wenige Tage, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass da äh nicht großartig, also wenn da mal ein Tag zu spät was reinkommt, ist das auch.
Wieso, wenn die das hören, dann haben sie noch mindestens vier Stunden.
Achten. Achtunddreißig Stunden die Woche TV ÖD äh Bund E dreizehn Stelle ähm ist da ausgeschrieben.
Ist das irgendwie eine Geldmetapher für für.
Nee, das das ist eine Besäudung.
Ach so, Besäugungsstufe. Aha, also wird man da wahrscheinlich irgendwie was äh keine Ahnung, wie viel ist denn das da? Na ja, also die manche Leute wissen das bestimmt.
Die Leute, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten, als ich, ich
glaube, so NGO-Stellen werden gerne mit TVÖD dreizehn irgendwie keine Ahnung, E, Weißdecker. Man kriegt Geld dafür. Äh Koordination der Vereinsarbeit und die Einbeziehung der Mitglieder
Entwicklung und Umsetzung strategischer Ziele, Leitlinien und Kampagnen des Vereins, die Vertretung des Vereins gegenüber Mediengeldgebern Stakeholdern sowie auf
in Gremien und auch Veranstaltungen. Die Planung des Vereinsbudgets, die Erarbeitung von Förderanträgen, das Management von Projekten des Vereins und die Personalführung äh würden dazu euren,
Aufgaben ge.
Als Mitglied.
Ich bin da Mitglied.
Wobei. Äh nein.
Aber ich bin, äh ich muss.
Also ich auch nicht, also wir haben keinen Interessenkonflikt, aber wir wollen ja nur offenlegen.
Bin in ich bin beim Verein digitale Gesellschaft glaube ich seit äh sehr, sehr, sehr langer Zeit nicht mehr nicht mehr.
Wollen ja nur ehrlich sein, ja? Wir können ja hier nicht Wiki Leaks was vorwerfen und selber keine Transparenz üben.
Ich habe Markus aber auch keine DMs geschrieben. Ähm ich habe keine ich habe glaube ich seit bei digitaler Gesellschaft wirklich seit dem Launch der Webseite äh nix mehr gemacht.
Aber jedenfalls würdest du auch Leute auffordern, dich zu bewerben. So ist nicht.
Unbedingt, weil ich glaube, dass man ähm,
mit diesem Verein noch vieles machen muss und vor allem eine hier der Schwerpunkt das strategisch aufzusetzen für die nächsten Jahre ähm
'ne sehr wichtige Aufgabe ist und dass der Verein wurde jetzt über Jahre aufgebaut und hat,
sich entwickelt und ähm man muss den jetzt ähm,
weiterbringen und der muss jetzt nochmal einen großen Schritt gehen und über sich selber nochmal hinauswachsen. Und äh da braucht man ähm,
die richtigen Leute führen. Sowohl im im Vorstand des Vereins, als auch in äh im täglichen Doing, wie ich letztens in einem in einem Meeting hörte.
Ich muss das mal in lustigerweise erzählen. Tim versucht die ganze Zeit rauszukriegen, was das wohl von Geld ist. Ich.
Tim mach dir, sitz hier mit dem Taschenrechner und sagt Metaebene.
Wie viel ist das?
Na ja, jetzt wo Buchhaltung mein äh Jahresthema ist.
Das ist sicherlich nicht das Geld. Also er hat jetzt er ist jetzt sehr viel weiter, das ist schon gehobener Dienst, was du jetzt hast.
A dreizehn. Du musst, du bist äh du bist A dreizehn, das ist.
Na ja, ich habe äh äh TÖVD Bund E 13 äh äh ist Qualifikationsstufe wissenschaftliches Hochschulstudium oder.
Da musst du ja unterscheiden. Also ich glaube das sind so ungefähr knapp unter fünfzigtausend Euro im Jahr. Wenn ich mich.
Was ist gehobener Dienst.
Na, was du jetzt noch hast, was ditter ist, gehobener Dienste.
Ne, das stand da aber TVÖD Bund E13
Wenn die, also bei denen sind wir bei deutlich mehr geht, dann sind wir bei über viertausend Euro im Monat oder sowas. Ja, aber.
Na ja, das steht da hier, er orientiert sich da dran.
Aber da ist ja auch sonst ja orientiert.
Und das sei wiederum identisch zu BAT, A dreizehn. Und BATA dreizehn ist halt irgendwie also kann man schon machen.
Ey, das ist nicht also der aber du jetzt hast das A dreizehn, das ist wirklich schon relativ gut bezahlt, da bist du schon jahrelang Beamter und so.
Das steht doch hier. Die Entgeltgruppen des TVÖD werden mit eins bis fünfzehn beziehungsweise E eins bis E fünfzehn durchnummeriert. Die Bezeichnungen sind dabei ähnlich zu den diejenigen, die Besoldungsgruppen eins bis A fünfzehn der Beamten.
Ja, ne, der Punkt ist, du orientierst dich jetzt an dem, was du liest und ich orientiere mich an Menschen, die kenne und weiß, was die für Geld verdienen. Das sind zwei Unterschiede.
Dann steht da vielleicht die falsche Information, keine Ahnung, also wenn ihr Interesse daran habt, irgendwie diesen Job anzunehmen.
Kriegt aber raus.
Fragst vielleicht.
Ein Job, den man fürs Geld machen sollte.
Sondern äh erstmal eine gute Ansage. Tim, wolltest du dich bewerben? Jetzt sag's uns, jetzt kannst du da.
Ich äh tauge nicht äh für diese Rolle. Bin da nicht qualifiziert.
Steht zur, steht zur Disposition diese diese Rolle übrigens bisher ähm ehrenvoll bekleidet von Alexander Sandner, den wir hier auch mehrmals schon in der Sendung hatten,
Damit werden wir.
Dreimal kommen wir zum Schluss sozusagen und ihr müsst ja noch unbedingt ihr müsstet zeigen nicht, ne? Hier verraten wir die jetzt gleich macht, ich war jetzt schon weiß.
Den anrufvollen Vortrag.
Ach so, das sagt dir, also das ist keine Überraschung für die Hörer. Ich muss ja immer vorsichtig sein.
Wir haben ja äh die null drei null einhundertzwanzig achtundachtzig drei achtundachtzig in der letzten Sendung angekündigt und äh wir werden gleich zum Ende der Sendung Fulltake.
Alles was ich gleich wieder aufgelegt hat.
Alles, was ich gleich wieder aufgelegt hat und alles, was nicht irgendwie äh also äh ne, wir werden so gut wie alle Anrufe äh äh die zumutbar sind ähm.
Also ich werde mir definitiv anhören, ich bin sehr neugierig, wer die euch drauf gequatscht haben. Ich bin ja ein Kommentarleser, ein bekennender äh insofern bin ich sehr neugierig, also so wie diese.
Wobei wir warten dann auch erstmal das Feedback ab, ob wir das nochmal machen. Jetzt machen wir es einfach mal.
Ob wir das dauern, also es sind jetzt natürlich schon relativ viele Anrufe gekommen. Was übrigens sehr schönes ist, ähm, ich hatte ja vor einigen Folgen mal gefragt, dass ich gerne wissen wollte, wann die Leute quasi wie lange nach der,
Nach der Veröffentlichung,
Es dauert bis die Leute auch wirklich LMP hören. Und da ist natürlich jetzt zu der Folge eine sehr schöne Kurve. Wann nämlich, dass das Anrufaufkommen am höchsten war und ähm das kann man jetzt ungefähr extra polieren auf ähm nach wie viel so zu welchen.
Ich finde ein ganz schlechtes Beispiel. Ich höre euch manchmal tatsächlich Monate und Jahre später. Also ich bin da wegen total schlechtes Beispiel und ob ich dann die Nummer noch erreichen würde, weiß ich nicht. Also bei mir ist natürlich oft ganz doll verzögert,
spannender oft zu hören, was ihr aktuell kommentiert habt, wenn das ein Jahr her ist. Ich kann das nur empfehlen, alte LNP Folgen,
Absolut.
Dann haben wir im Ernst, die waren besser, ne? Die alten. Die alten Alben waren besser.
Ach nee, ihr habt ihr habt unterschiedliche, also nee, na ja, ihr habt unterschiedliche Formen, also manchmal merkt man, dass es sehr gesprächig ist und manchmal ist es so ein, also ist es nicht so, aber alle Folgen sind geil, weil sich nach einem Jahr oder zweites wie bei No you know, womit wir angefangen haben.
Ich wollte wusste, dass du da wieder hinter, ich habe mir gedacht, so, die Constanze will jetzt irgendwie die Kurve nochmal zu einem kriegen mit alten Sachen.
Ihr seid so gemein. Nein, also da ick das immer tue, kann ich das euch praktisch sagen,
höre alte Podcasts und das ist interessant, weil die Welt sich dann weiterdreht. Und diesen hier nach ein oder zwei Jahren zu hören, wenn das Urteil schon da ist und man zum Beispiel gesehen hat, genau und die Nacktpfote schon alle geliegt sind von Facebook. Nee, das ist doch spannend.
Wo man sich denkt, guck mal, da lachen sie alle hämisch. Hätten sie mal ihre Bilder hochgeladen.
Ihr wart auch oft in den Voraussagen nicht so schlecht muss ich mal sagen.
Ja, neulich habe ich eine gehört, da redet ihr über ähm den als ziemlich den Beginn des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses,
ihr gerade drüber, das ist das Aktuelle, ist bestimmt schon äh bestimmt drei Jahre alt gewesen oder so. Ich fand das sehr interessant, weil ihr oft natürlich liegt ja auch mancher daneben, aber ihr habt oft eine interessante Sicht und die äh hat sich im Nachhinein oft als Wahl herausgestellt,
oder auch als lustige, also manche Witze von euch sind nach drei Jahren lustiger als ähm zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Noch lustiger? Die reifen nach.
Die Reifen wie ein guter Verein.
Aber das liegt an mir. Ich habe da so ein technisches Problem, weswegen ich äh in der Regel sehr alte Podcast-Theore. Schätze du das aber ich finde das schön. Ich habe keinen Aktualitätsterror überhaupt nicht.
Hat er denn eigentlich das deutsche Technik Museum für dein Abspielgerät schon ein Angebot gemacht?
Nein. Fies, oder.
Ähm.
Los, jetzt, ich habe Hunger. Ich hasse Hunger. Ja, muss was.
Also der ist nicht gut, wenn Tim Humig ist, dann wird er wird er ungenätig.
Also wir werden den Anruf beantworten.
Nicht so schlimm wie andere Leute.
Gänse abspielen bis auf eine Nachricht, wo ein anonymer Anrufer, ein Pseudonym, einer anderen Person gelüftet hat und das bin ich,
geht nicht, also Pseudonyme lüften geht sowieso nicht und dat dann noch anonym zu tun, kann ich nur als Scherz auffassen. Vielleicht reift er auch nochmal mit Alter dieser Witz, aber den haben wir rausgenommen. Ähm ansonsten äh kommt hier eine lange Liste dank,
An Manuela Patrick Andre. Ralf, zwei Mal der gleiche Ralf übrigens, Lukas, Philipp Henning, der eine Henning,
Kai, Jan Jakob, Nico, eine unbekannte Person, Jan Falk, Alexander Falk, Markus Kai, Holger, Peter, Alexander Christian und der andere Henning,
Und äh die unbekannte Personen können sich ähm bitte gerne melden. Die äh da will ich danke ja hier gerne äh an dieser Stelle,
öffentlich.
Ja, jetzt sind die Musik schweigen, du guckst mich jetzt an. Aber ok.
Versorgung ist sichergestellt, Constanze. Wenn du das nächste Mal kommst, habe ich auf jeden Fall noch Kaffee.
Yay.
Nun gut, eine weitere über lange Folge. Ich hoffe, wir kommen ja irgendwie nochmal einen normalen Modus. Ähm ist in the Can. Wie man so schön sag.
Vielen Dank Constanze.
Tschüss, wenn könnt ihr mich nach einem Jahr mal wieder einladen.
Cha Chao.
Tschüss.